this is jocko podcast number 303
with carrie helton and me jocko willink
good evening carrie good evening also
joining us tonight is dave burke good
evening dave good evening
so dave i've been
sitting on this for a while sitting on
this book for a while i think i i think
i've been sitting on it for almost a
year
almost a year i've been sitting on this
book and i've been waiting for
the right time to cover this book
and i don't think there's a better time
than right now the reason that i don't
think there's a better time than right
now you'll figure out as soon as i say
the title of the book
the title of the book is on the
psychology on the psychology of military
incompetence
on the psychology of military
and
what does that mean well one thing it
means is
as we look at military
leaders
a lot of times people think oh this
individual is in the military they must
be awesome i mean look it happens a
hundred percent in the seal community oh
this guy was a seal he must be
of the highest character must be an
unbelievable leader must be a great
runner right must be great at pull-ups
and swimming must be the best shot right
so so
people make assumptions about the seal
teams oh if you were sealed and you must
be able to survive at a minimum of 78
days
with
you know nothing but a loin cloth and uh
and a toothpick right that's
that that's kind of you can you you
you're picking up what i'm putting down
right
same thing happens with leadership you
think oh this individual's in the in the
military they made life and death
decisions they must be incredible
leaders
and we can also attribute that to
leaders in the past too well this person
was a general this person was
you know
a military leader in
the 1800s in the 1600s they must have
military brilliance
well this
book disputes that not whole not not not
as a whole and he makes a very
important point
and i had this discussion with jason
gardner the other day
after the afghanistan podcast jason's
like well there's a lot of good leaders
and i said yeah there absolutely are and
i've worked for a lot of incredible
leaders in the military
but to blanket all leaders in the
military and say oh they're in the
military so they're awesome is a bad
move
and you can actually say throughout
history there have been some really bad
leaders and it's relatively consistent
that you get bad military leaders bad
senior military leaders so
this is something i was interested in
this book is written guy uh by a guy
named dr
norman f dixon
and and i i don't really remember where
i originally heard about the book it
might have been one of the
like
algorithmic recommendations which
do we hate the algorithm kind of but
sometimes we're a little bit stoked
about the algorithm so i might have been
an algorithm it might have been maybe
somebody recommended it to me
but
i look at it and obviously i like the
military that's what this podcast is
we do all kinds of military subjects on
this podcast obviously i like psychology
as well and the
much of the jocko underground podcast
we've covered a bunch of
psychology
but when it comes to military stuff i
like military books that are written by
military people not books that are
written by theorists or even historians
and academics that haven't been there
so i don't normally
like those kind of
military books that are written by
someone that was in the military so i
wasn't sure if this book would make the
grade
then i did some research and
here's the deal the author dr norman
dixon
mbe
which is british-like thing
most excellent order of british empire
which you're given for
your
achievements in the arts and sciences
he received his doctorate in philosophy
in 1956 doctor of science 1972 1976 he
was awarded
sorry 1956 that's a 1956 doctrine in
philosophy 1956 doctrine in philosophy
doctor of science 1972 1976 awarded the
university of london carpenter medal for
quote work of exceptional distinction in
experimental psychology
right so the guy has some
some clout bringing home some hardware
he's bringing home some hardware
he's
a professor
emeritus at
of psychology at the university of
university college of london authored
other books besides this one one's
called our own worst enemy kind of like
that title another one called
unconscious processing another one
called subliminal perception so that's
all impressive
still wasn't sure if it made the grade
but what tied it all together for me is
that prior to all this stuff that he did
he was in the british army from 1940
till 1950 and that means he fought in
world war ii was wounded in world war ii
wounded and this is a quote according to
him he was wounded quote largely through
my own incompetence which is
we at least we're coming out of the gate
with some humility which is nice
but it gives
it means his perspective
is
he has that perspective of a soldier of
someone that's fought if someone that's
been in combat then he can overlay that
on his academic knowledge but the book
is
i mean you're going to see real quick
that this book is pretty
it's a pretty incredible book and and i
don't know
how many podcasts
we'll do on it i'm assuming it'll be two
maybe three um i don't know how much
we'll even be able to get through
get through today
but with that
i'm gonna start off with the forward of
the book which is written by a guy named
jeffrey walrow i hope i'm saying that
right if not i apologize to jeffrey
weiro
professor of military history university
of north texas director of their
military history center and this is this
is his
his forward to the book
which
the reason i wanted to read the forward
is because it starts to lay out
the themes inside this book
and you start to get an understanding of
where this guy's coming from
anything
makes sense so far
this is a book that i was burning
through highlighters
it's almost one of the books where
you might as well just stop highlighting
because you're highlighting everything
so here we go
the the forward
to norm dixon's on the psychology of
military incompetence norman dixon's
on the psychology of military
incompetence is a classic that should be
read not because it is true in every
detail but because it offers the
military historian analyst or student an
important method to discover and rank
the manifold reason for military error
and defeat that's a bold statement
coming out of the gate
he's saying the manifold reasons for
military air and defeat are found in
this book
coming out of the gate strong
and there's a couple notes in there not
true in every detail the reason for that
is the way the book is laid out it
covers a lot of historical battles and
wars
and i think that i think that dixon was
sensitive being an academic about the
way historians would read it be like
well actually that date is wrong and so
he's he covers that himself too and says
look
ballpark we're in there this is what
happened it's not and i didn't go and
fact check everything but
ballpark this is what happened so it's
not a historical reference and he says
that later continuing on dixon deploys
psychological theory in a lucid
accessible way and applies it in several
case studies spanning the 19th century
and 20th centuries
he is in some ways constrained by chrono
chronology the british officer types he
scrutinizes are creatures of their age
boris conservative and authoritarian
and this authoritarian piece that he's
talking about
this may be the underlying theme of the
book this authoritarian attitude and and
personality type
and what it means and what it does to
you and what it does to your people
continue on they went to stuffy boarding
schools and endured tyrannical parents
and school teachers they enlisted in a
class system that expected snobbish
conformity
and yet the deeper you read into the
book the more you realize that the
specific circumstances of a raglan hague
montgomery are less important than their
lifelong enlistment in the military
hierarchy that constrains and often
warps behavior
and you can see starting to throw out
names raglan hey montgomery so that's
what this book is he refers to
individuals and shows what they did well
what they did bad and he does cover good
leaders as well
at the heart of this book is a thesis
that all can accept
all human decision makers are victims of
a chronic hazard
that emotion and motivation
unconsciously distort and bias all
thought and perception
right it's like crazy this is what we
talk about all the time
detached from your emotions
you get distorted what do you write in
ego clouds
all decisions right that's what he's
talking about man's needs
biological social or neurotic
act on his perception of the world
around him and the decisions he makes
no one in other words operates cleanly
what a good thing to remember
no one operates cleanly you all have it
going on
i did the underground podcast a while
back
and i talked about the fact that we're
all insane
and that is something
the definition of insanity is that
your world doesn't match reality
and the fact of the matter is my world
doesn't match your reality dave i know
we're probably pretty freaking close
because we work in the same job we have
a similar background
but there's no way that you see things
exactly the way i see it right kerry you
and i have a similar background
but
there's no way that we match up our
realities don't match so that means
we're all insane
it's just a matter of what degree
and that means everyone you interact
with is kind of insane that means their
reality is different than yours so when
you're in a leadership position you're
dealing with other people their reality
is different than you so when you're
making a decision
and they hear that decision their
reality is different than yours
no one
in other words operates cleanly
singleness of mind a key ingredient of
successful command is always under siege
by doubt worries and distractions we all
churn through a sludge of life
experiences that have formed us and left
us with key strengths and weaknesses
the challenge for military commanders is
all the greater because the stakes of
their decisions are so high and because
they operate in stressful environments
amid hunger fatigue heat or cold sleep
deprivation and the relentless ticking
of the clock
not for nothing did napoleon call
unforgiving time
the grand element in warfare
which is epic because lately i've been
talking about the
the the leadership loop
and the number one thing i said you have
to consider the number one thing that's
in the front of my mind all the time in
any leadership situation is time
what does he call the grand element time
is what you have to think about and
sometimes the thought is oh we got
plenty of time which is cool
but you got to think about that
people that don't keep time in front of
mind
they're always behind they're always
behind
bro we're two paragraphs dude
i know
and i almost said something go ahead go
ahead what do you got i just
i always like hearing how these people
write
and the word like this is a good writer
this guy writes well yeah i mean this is
just the forward bro
but the fact that he went through all
those things he was talking about heat
cold and i don't even remember all the
words
uh and when he got to time he added the
the additional component of um
it can relent yeah or we've got maybe
some technology that that we're gonna
wear a coat or some cold weather like we
can mitigate all these other things
but time is
unrelenting there is no mitigation and
that is that will be
forever forever yeah we're not gonna
technology our way out of the time issue
like oh we'll just slow time down like
we can manage the heat and all those
other elements i just like the way they
he adds that piece to it and what's
already like just a good the way he
writes is awesome that's why as a leader
and as a person it has to be the number
one thing you think about
it's the only thing that will give you
no no slack whatsoever right no zero
that's it it that clock is ticking
dixon uses several case studies to
elucidate military incompetence he
begins with the crimean war which
britain undertook in an era of rapid
industrialization prosperity and
commercial dominance
wouldn't it what do you think if you've
got rapid industrialization prosperity
and commercial dominance you just go
crush everyone on the battlefield what
do you think that
victorian britain was the last word in
yet its military stumbled from one
bloody disaster to the next piling up 21
000 mostly avoidable dead
how could this be in view of britain's
world leadership much of it dixon finds
had to do with the command performance
of 66 year old lord raglan
an extreme introvert who died of severe
depression during the campaign raglan
drifted like a rudderless ship the
officers under him suffered a familiar
dilemma
if they took matters into their own
hands they could be accused of
insubordination if they let the
rudderless ship drift further they could
be accused of incompetence
that's a catch-22
ultimately
nothing was done
and the british troops and taxpayers
bore the brunt of their
systemic and command incompetence of
which the notorious charge of the light
brigade was but the thin end of the
wedge
since authoritarian organizations again
you're going to hear this word and it
took me a while to pick up on it even
though it's really obvious to me right
now this authoritarian attitude
is is like this underlying one of the
underlying themes throughout this since
authoritarian organizations like the
military are masters at shifting blame
the time-honored tactic of the cornered
child
the british army survived the fiasco of
the korean crimean war
unreformed so they went through all that
21 000 dead
who knows what the price tag was
no reforms
a major theme of this book
is in the incurability of military
organizations they must be removed from
their pedestals cracked open and filled
with daylight which is another way of
saying subjected to rigorous scrutiny
and review unfortunately they rarely are
raglan's folly which made the crimean
war
in dixon's judgment the prototype for
protracted military incompetence was
followed by the boor war
somehow despite the similarities of the
two campaigns fought far away for
imperial interests britain applied no
lessons learned from the crimean
campaign
london's performance in 1899 was even
worse than 1855. it's quote military
incompetence straining credibly to the
breaking point
indeed the british officers took pride
in their amateurness their clubby
good fellowship and their conviction
that any effort at self-improvement were
bad form i'm going to say that again
imagine you're in a
group of people where self-improvement
is considered bad form
they clung to unhelpful routines like
sand crabs clinging to seaweed in storm
time
they battled gorillas on the south
african belt with luxuriant baggage
including pianos
gramophones
chests of drawers
polo mallets and mobile kitchens and
bathrooms
they're fighting against the booers
savages you're just getting just
horrible yeah
general redverse buller commanded the
expedition like raglan he was in over
his head he lacked command experience
imagination and confidence he was
passive and defeatist the booers swept
over him like a turret
he never stopped retreating and the
press nicknamed him reverse buller
field marshall douglas hague's command
in world war one is an obvious place to
stop and relish the psychology of
military incompetence
since dixon's book there has been a
vigorous debate about hague for and
against but few would dispute that
hague's psychology had much to do with
his
his mediocre to abysmal performance as
british expeditionary force commander he
was an old cavalryman with an outmoded
view of warfare
he'd been ruled as a boy by a stern
religious mother he was solitary aloof
and inspired by an obsessive need for
order and this is another one of those
things that's sort of the authoritarian
mindset you want everything to be
organized you want everything to be in
order and i'll say and i'm not a i'm not
a super psychological nerd or psychology
nerd but he definitely dips into like
the childhood stuff probably a little
bit more than i would and the reason i
think
i don't dip as much into the childhood
stuff is
i've known people that had authoritarian
parents and didn't end up like this
right had whatever
religious
strict parents and ended up
you know in every level every type of
different person i've known people that
had total hippies for parents and let
the kids do whatever they want and i've
seen those kids end up in different
places on the spectrum so i don't know
if i
i don't know if i i don't know if i
correlate these things as as much or put
as much weight on the upbringing
as
dixon does
but that's just me it's interesting to
know it could be it's definitely a
contributing factor depending on how
your personality reacts to it because i
mean
we you and i have kids dave
the kids are different
like the kids are different you could
put them in a controlled environment
with the exact same
situation because you know oh the ones
the middle child the ones the oldest and
so oh so that means you treat them
differently well even if you put them in
a controlled environment
they got personalities
and that personality is going to come
out yeah
um
so obsessive need forward it took him
too long to grasp just how radically
technology like machine guns and heavy
artillery had changed warfare and
rendered most of what he'd learned at
staff college in the 1890s obsolete
incredibly hague insisted to the end of
the war that the battles he was engaged
in were not quote normal warfare
which is just a bizarre
mindset like this this isn't normal
we'll get back to normal
this is just happening right now this is
normal that that's again that reality
versus mindset or perception like this
is reality this is this is your normal
yeah you know yeah then he hasn't
figured that out negative
he's insane insane
worse
he gave his subordinates the singular
gift of the authoritarian defined by
dixon as
a terrible crippling obedience
officers had to implement haig's vague
instructions he left much in doubt
because he was so unsure of himself or
be replaced and disgraced
haig's influence was awful british
officers under him were expected to
attack and show quote offensive spirit
even against the most invincible
defensive fire this was to demonstrate
quote pluck and quote dash and quote
optimism can you even fathom that
you're in world war one
and my address to you dave is like hey
dave all right listen mate what i want
you to do is just i want you to charge
with all your heart and show that to
show the enemy that you've got some puck
and some dash
by the way yesterday you watch your
entire battalion get mowed down or your
friend's battalion get mowed down
to shelter in the trenches was to
exhibit the disqualifying sin of
pessimism
dave what's wrong mate what you doing
down there in the trench why don't you
get up there go on
go on son
it's it's the disqualifying like it
isn't like hey hey let's let's pull dave
out of his funk here he's like oh he's
he he's incapable of doing this because
he's his behavior it reveals that he's
pessimistic pessimistic about living and
this is a guy who you said i think the
quote was took too long to recognize the
impact of the machine gun how many
engagements with a machine gun do you
need before you go oh yeah things are
different now you don't even need one
complete engagement by the way yeah you
get
you get one volley of fire and you go oh
just changed everybody get back in
the briefing room we need a new plan
[Music]
all armies began the great war like this
but only hague kept it up until 1917
coldly firing officers who wouldn't
follow his ghastly directives
prudently dispatched from a chateau
dozens of miles behind the lines
dixon's brilliant description of the
military authoritarian fits hague like a
savile row suit
superficial toughness and
ordering leanness
are quote a brittle crust of defense
against feelings of weakness and
inadequacy the authoritarian keeps up
his spirits by whistling in the dark he
is the frightened child who wears the
armor of a giant his mind is a door
locked and bolted shut against that
which he fears most himself
the imagery is outstanding here this
guy's yeah he's hit middlemen
all readers will appreciate the drift of
dixon's book which might be summarized
in george bernard shaw's wartime quip
that quote the british soldier can stand
up to anything except the british war
office
micromanaging and stifling of initiative
are byproducts of the hierarchical
military system
a yearning for old certainties like the
horse and the battleship even when tanks
and aircraft carriers made them obsolete
is understandable only when psychology
is deployed there is unquestionably in
any military in any epoch
a prevailing culture of obedience and
group loyalty a deliberate process of
military socialization as two esteemed
psychologists wrote in their 1989 work
on the social psychology of authority
once the military culture of obedience
is established by training and service
men are quote governed not so much by
motivational processes
what they want
as by
perceptual ones what they see required
of them
dixon sees fear as the common
denominator in the general
psychopathology of military
organizations
and this is interesting fear of the bad
performance review not fair getting shot
not fair of a machine gun but fear of a
bad performance review not surprisingly
then fear of failure overshadows hope of
success leading to complacency group
think and bad decisions so if if i'm
afraid of a bad performance review
i'm i probably don't want to do anything
right i'm probably my go-to is like i'm
just going to sit here and we're not
going to do anything
at best i'm saying well if that's what
dave's doing i guess we'll all get in
trouble dave will get in trouble first
so i'll do what he's doing status quo
yeah status quo all day
attacking the flaws in a military plan
was as dangerous to an officer's career
in 2003 as in 1901
officers around secretary of defense
donald rumsfeld and u.s central command
centcom leader general tommy franks had
to bite their tongues when even the most
preposterous plans were floated
the same went for officers in vietnam
pushing for a low-intensity
counter-insurgency war as opposed to a
high-tempo conventional one was not the
way to get ahead in an army that had
made firepower and mobility its mantra
military organizations dixon tells us
can create incompetence uniformity
and a greying hierarchy the system all
too often creates mediocrity as bright
officers adapt to the plan and
institutional priorities which are
frequently at odds with reality and best
practices
a recent example of this would be the us
army's decision not to deploy large
numbers of ground troops to capture or
kill osama bin laden in 2001.
he was trapped in eastern afghanistan
near the khyber pass the army had only
to cordon off his cave complex and
escape routes with troops
but so insistent was secretary rumsfeld
on keeping this force small in order to
demonstrate the stripped-down power of
the army and its expeditionary potential
and to leave troops off-ramp for an
invasion of iraq that centcom commander
tommy franks didn't insist on
reinforcements
nor would he have anywhere nor would he
have anyway for ta frank for frank's
took pride in never contradicting the
famously cantankerous rumsfeld
in the clinch franks lacked moral
courage and common failing among
ingratiating authoritarians
bin laden escaped and would remain at
large for 10 more years
cognitive dissonance is another danger
of the military organization memoirs
from centcom and washington remind us
that most clear thinking officers
recognize the failures of rumsfeld and
franks even in real time but felt
compelled to keep silent
the one who didn't
army chief of staff general eric
shinseki who insisted that massive
numbers of u.s troops would be needed to
stabilize a defeated iraq
was ridiculed and driven into retirement
for the crime of speaking truth to power
this reinforces dixon's point that it is
not stupidity that leads to incompetence
but rather the dead hand of the
authoritarian personality
which is an interesting take so he has
to say that throughout the book because
it's really easy just to say hey these
guys were stupid but they're not stupid
in many cases they're really freaking
smart
military organizations all too often
force their members to act incompetently
when asked by president george w bush to
distinguish his views on the 9 11 wars
from runsfelds
general tommy franks weirdly replied
sir
i think exactly what my secretary thinks
what he's ever thought what he will
think or whatever he thought he might
think
given the dreadful stakes in the wars
this was incompetence on stilts franks
like general william westmoreland is a
fine example of the peter principle also
referenced by dixon by which leaders are
promoted beyond their capabilities to an
unimagined level of incompetence and
efficiency so the peter principal
says that
oh dave
oh dave did a good job as a squad leader
let's make him a platoon leader okay did
a good job as a platoon leader let's
make him a company commander oh he did a
good job as a company commander let's
make him a battalion commander but he's
not capable so he's not capable but
that's his position
he's not competent in that position but
and what you end up with is everybody
promotes
to now you don't get promoted to brigade
commander but it doesn't matter you're a
battalion commander yeah
so now we have a bunch guess what all
the other battalion commanders or most
of them all the same thing they're all
promoted to their level of incompetence
right
of course general franks thought that he
was being submissive and funny he was
speaking
what dixon calls throughout the book
keeping up appearances in this way is
the essence of authoritarian structures
proving one's reliability even a bad
even in a bad cause the internal
politics of in war or peace
inexorably become a substitute for
incisive thinking this decreases
initiative and increases dependency
there is a huge irony for the pattern of
modern warfare from dixon's period to
our own has been to require more and
more independence and initiative as
information and intelligence pass more
quickly and in greater volume down the
chain of command
so
even though we've gotten worse
and we become more authoritarian the f
the flow of information and the ability
to maneuver and think for yourself has
increased
so we're going in the wrong direction
dixon forces us to reconsider the
assumption that military organizations
operate as effective teams
in fact they are often anything but
effective
the difficulties britain's interwar
reformers
jfc fuller and basil ladell hart had in
inducing the british army establishment
to
quote thresh the grist from the traff
chaff in conventional theories of war as
full reported are legendary fuller in
the 1920s saw new technologies like the
tank and the airplane as able to leap
from the muscular warfare of the great
war to a faster quicker
deadlier
less destructive
mechanized warfare that would administer
quick relative bloodless
shot through the brain not the
interminable pounding with flesh and
guns that had characterized world war
one
so you had people after world war one
that and we've covered in great detail
bh little delhard in this podcast
hey we don't need to do it that way that
way it didn't make much sense liddell
hart in 1926 considered the british
army's problems of institutional
rigidity and stuffiness
so great that he equated it with illness
arguing for the army's quote inoculation
with the serum of mobility
the army was unmoved forcing gadflies
like liddell hart into early retirement
god
you know what we don't really like what
you're saying why don't you retire
dixon's account of liddell heart lacks
the more recent scholarship on the
rather slippery british theorist but he
rightly cites that the captain as just
the sort of man a military organization
finds intolerable
brash
bright insightful eloquent and
opinionated
that's who we don't like
that's who we don't want we don't want
someone that's bright that's brash
that's insightful that's eloquent
and opinionated we don't want that
person it's a potent human being right
it's a potent human being it's it's got
to watch out for them
and it's interesting because
you know maybe if liddell hart had read
his own book and maybe taken a little
bit more of an indirect approach on some
of these things he might have done a
little bit better convincing the chain
of command
right 100 he didn't get to read his own
book he didn't have that luxury
unfortunately for him
because he went hard
and told them they needed the to be
inoculated with the serum of mobility
that's a rough thing to say up the chain
of command
you're telling your your leadership they
need to get inoculate there you need you
need to completely change what you're
doing you need an inoculation that's a
that's that's a bold attack that's a
frontal attack that's a direct attack
nothing indirect about that
he became what he became a prophet
he was a prophet and what happens a
prophet he told us what happens to
prophet they get fired
they get stoned they get stoned they get
crucified that's what happens to
prophets
and he was a prophet and what happened
to him got drummed down to the army
there seems to be a place where
there's a
transformation that happens where these
um
i don't i don't want to call them
students but
these kind of rebels become the prophet
though right like where there it goes
from a
kind of a detached perspective to a
no this is what needs to happen why
won't you listen you know putting that
kind of thought forward i feel like
they become you know
if you start to get emotional
which which can happen especially when
you've got lives at stake or you're what
you know you just pointed to hackworth's
book
hackwork reached a point where he look
he was trying to persuade people and
talking about how we should do it and
did it with his own battalion and showed
what the results were
you know we need to do a counter
insurgency we need we need to be not
going head-to-head we need to act like
gorillas right we need to fight like
gorillas he was doing that he was
showing the results
but at a certain point like you just
said you are correct a certain point
they say you know what
we got to stop doing this
and they become a prophet and they
become martyr
and liddell hart
became a martyr and got drummed out of
the army david hackworth became a martyr
got drummed out of the army
whether that helped or not
didn't help immediately
um
liddell hart's last act in uniform was
to submit an essay on the mechanization
of the army for a military competition
liddell hart lost to an essay titled
limitations of the tank
that's crazy right you can't make that
up
you can't make that up
little bit of irony there
and they about to get blitzcragged like
you read about
you know what i'm saying they got
blitzcrate straight up that's what went
down
on britain's failure to embrace armored
warfare in time to affect the fighting
of 1940 liddell hart recalled if a
soldier advocates any new idea of real
importance he builds up such a wall of
obstruction
compounded of resentment suspicion and
inertia that the idea only succeeds at
the sacrifice of himself
as the wall finally yields to the
pressure of the new idea it falls and
crushes him
so he that's him saying he did become
the martyr right
this is the process of military
incompetence
vested interests bureaucratic turfs
defensive services and uncertain leaders
all contribute to a stifling of
innovation and all too often a
scapegoating of innovators
inevitably dixon cites the great french
statement
george clemenceau
in this context quote war is too serious
a business to be left to the generals
that's no joke
fuller
who had commanded britain's tank corps
in world war one later said fighting the
germans is a joke compared
with fighting the british
the blimpish generals conservatives of a
dead military epoch simply would not be
budged to be fair there was no easy
solution britain had to prepare for war
simultaneously in europe against the
germans and all across its empire
against a range of potential enemies
like italy japan and indian or
palestinian nationalists tanks might
work against the germans but they'd be
acquired at the expense of the tools
needed to fight the small wars around
the fringes of the empire that was no
excuse
for lethargy yet lethargy is precisely
what flourishes in the world of the
author authoritarian where vigorous
debate and reform are interpreted as a
frontry
can't even debate
can't even debate we're not even having
debates around here
and you can picture that authoritarian
platoon commander he doesn't want to
hear a debate about the way we should do
this mission
doesn't want to debate about that the
authoritarian ceo of the company doesn't
want to debate about how we're going to
move into this new market area he wants
people to shut up
and do what i told you to do
in france charles de gaulle battled
the same sort of establishment he wanted
a small professional army highly mobile
and leveraged with air power his ideas
broke against the power of the old
sweats
like generals maurice gaimlin and
philippe pettane who looked back
serenely on the victory of 1918 and saw
the future as just an elaboration of
that not something new
tanks betaine characteristically snorted
are the sancho ponzas
two weighted down to fight sancho ponz
is a character in uh
don quixote he's like a comic relief fat
guy that can't really fight
that criticism recalled don quixote
himself who told sancho one fine day too
much sanity may be madness
and maddest of all to see life as it is
and not as it should be
and of course there was no more twisted
authoritarian than joseph stalin who
literally destroyed the reforms of
martial mikhail
turkichevsky
turkaczewski's deep battle idea might
have made the red army as formidable as
the germans in time for world war ii
it called for quote linked and
simultaneous destructive operations and
quote mechanized operational warfare
carried on the backs of tanks
stalin killed turkicevsky and all of his
acolytes in the purge of 1937.
he's got some good ideas whatever
the general had studied the germans too
closely he appeared threatening and
suspicious to stalin to stalin precisely
because of his restless mind and broad
professional circle the two things that
should have made him a fine model
officer not a criminal
the army that survived the purges
was a scarcely improved version of the
clumsy peasant force of world war one
it would perform about as well in its
early campaigns
imagine you you're france and you get
done with world war one and you're like
what do we need to change
we won
and you know the germans were like we
lost what can we change
maybe if they would have won they
wouldn't wouldn't have
changed what they did would have come up
with the blitz craig
speaking of which for the victors of
world war 1 the victory proved
intellectually crippling
old weapons
mean old tactics and whereas the germans
were plucked clean of weapons in 1919
and forced to begin anew with tanks and
aircraft the victorious allies clung to
what had worked infantry artillery and
field fortifications which reached their
apogee with the maginot line all of this
reinforced a military tendency to do
nothing
nothing was safer in the crabbed minds
of these men
than the risk of failed ventures
the dixon's mind is the military
authoritarian's lack of emotional
maturity that makes him or her so
dangerous to the organization even one
seated liberally with other
authoritarians passive
dependent insecure they are in dixon's
word
frightened children
in the army in the armor of men
the worst mischief happens when they are
promoted to supreme command not because
they overreach but because they have
risen to that rank by obeying orders
suddenly with no one above them be they
become unmoored which is a scary thing
right who gets promoted
i'm promoting the person that obeyed me
if i'm an authoritarian
who's getting promoted that's the way i
should have framed that question i'm
promoting the person that obeyed me i'm
definitely not promoting dave burke that
asked me a bunch of questions every time
i put out some word i'm definitely not
promoting carrie who's you know got some
comment at the end of my briefing
that seems a little bit undermining
you're not getting promoted neither you
i got a yes man over here getting
promoted
they compensate for their for this
weightlessness
with procrastination
with more or busy work and a
retreat into familiar routines and
habits in battle
they might waste their men or suffer a
paralyzing compassion for them and
you're
the like uh
i don't know
in the
navy
or maybe i'm getting this from hollywood
i don't know
no i think it's from the navy we called
um you know polishing your boots
chicken chicken stuff right do you
guys have anything like that in the
marine corps
definitely have that term okay would you
would you apply the term chicken
to polishing boots to pressing your
uniform to starching your
eight-sided cover
doing things that you know mean nothing
okay yeah chicken just marine corps
carry confirm so um disc confirmed
negative i i we didn't use chicken
uh and and generation yeah yeah new core
yeah yeah you guys called it chicken poo
chicken
poultry
but that's a real thing so what's
interesting is
he goes into this and says
you know if i don't know what to do with
dave like i'm not sure what the guess
what i do you know polish your boots
yeah
that's the distinction
because as i'm saying that i was like
hey the message isn't like you don't
need to shine your boots or have a good
looking uniform because that stuff
doesn't actually that stuff does matter
but that stuff matters in a different
much like when we hear what hacker's
rules were hey here's what i do here's
why we're going to do it here's the
reason why those things are important as
opposed to
if i got a doll out of punishment
and i got to make you do stuff with your
time that is a complete and total waste
of time that's what the term my
recollection of maybe a generational
thing is like what are we doing we're
sitting around um
we're gonna uh uh um
what do we do the strip watch the floor
yeah
we're gonna strip around the floors
again why you can tell i wasn't enlisted
there you go yeah yeah
so back stripped and whack some floors
yeah that's the distinction right there
you know and there's this fam there's a
meme out there now it's this famous
picture it's a picture of a marine
um
with like a squeegee like squeegeeing
the you know the the parade deck in a
rainstorm yeah i got it just get back
yes we did have a green weenie was the
go-to you're getting the green weenie
there was what we'd call that yeah yeah
right so i mean
yeah
but another thing he he was talking
about kind of the hallmark or the i
don't know freaking
um sentiment in this authoritarian
regime um he said lethargy
and paralyzation and there's this type
of language that that kind of punishment
doling out does to troops
that it's just this
i don't even care like i just don't i
don't care you know and that's kind of
that chicken or
green weeny vibe that you get when
that's the kind of kind of leadership
history is littered with such examples
general george mcclellan was paralyzed
by his vast responsibilities as lincoln
lincoln's general in chief
general ludwig benedek
had excellent chance to destroy the
prussian army
in 1866 but he didn't dare
general
general bazine stood with a concentrated
french army between widely separated
german armies in 1870 but failed the
strike in any direction effectively
permitting the prussians to unite their
armies and win the franco-prussian war
one historian
accurately described hague's command in
world war one as a quote floating
helpless whale
so slow was haig's
so slow was hague to issue detailed
direct instructions to his subordinate
commanders and solve the problem of the
german defensive fire
officers with general maurice gamlin
who commanded the french army in may
1940 when german panzers knifed across
the muse
described gamelan as quote stricken by a
dull and pervasive fear end quote
instead of leading a counter-attack
against the nazi invasion invaders the
french general sat passively in army
headquarters at vincennes
a colleague there described him thus
quote he was like a submarine without a
periscope end quote
u.s general john lucas landed on
undefended beaches at anzio 1944 yet
fearfully dug in instead of thrusting to
rome giving the far away germans time to
react and circle him and lengthen the
war
man that that that
that fear
of making a call
that's every one of those examples is
just i'm afraid to make a call
the best generals
dixon concludes
have been the mavericks
leaders like irwin rommel horatio nelson
and napoleon bonaparte men who had the
intelligence confidence to resist and
roll back the negative psychology of the
military organization
unfortunately the average general is not
this sort of man
dixon notes that military leaders are
often chosen for their affability or
appearance
like general buller big bone square
jawed or general neil ritchie tobruck
a great air of
decisiveness but the bluff
appearance too often masks doubt and
pessimism as t e lawrence would say in
the same context
too much body and too little head
you know what's interesting about this
is i was talking to somebody um
at an event i was just at
and there's a certain military
like a military bearing right we use
that term military bearing people can
utilize military bearing and you see
leaders do this in the military all the
time
they utilize military bearing as a
it's like a defensive mechanism you know
you talk like this you put the word out
you you you fur your brow a little bit
and you say no this is what we need to
get done right now
and and they get good at it they become
brow beaters but they're so good at it
that people are like well i mean
okay i mean that's yeah they kind of
back off
and and becomes a technique
so it's beyond just the way that they
look but they start to learn how to act
that's gonna just kind of allow them to
sort of get away with
either not doing something or doing
something that doesn't make sense they
just kind of
you know drop their voice a little bit
and and sort of you know
stand up straight get that posture going
and look someone in the eyes and say you
you need to stand down
so dave burke raises and says hey boss
i'm wondering if we should worry about
that high ground hey burke
you need to worry about what you need to
worry about and people get good enough
at that little act
that
burke submits right because
you're asking an honest question but
you're not quite it's an earnest
question you're not even you're asking a
real question
and i come at you with that hey burke
you didn't don't need to worry about
that you need to stay in your lane i got
this covered
and your response is like oh okay you
know
roger that that plus seniority oh yeah
plus a little bit of rank or whatever on
the caller there i mean that's that'll
shut down all kinds of pushback
is that how you operated dave
dude you see that i
i call that brow beating do you guys
ever heard that term before brow beating
yeah i call that browbeaters and there's
plenty of leaders that that that's their
leadership style that they you know they
could write a book if they were to try
and write leadership strategy and
tactics it would just be called like
leadership through browbeating and they
could go through listen when someone
starts asking a question first of all
you need to elevate your voice a little
bit you need to elevate your voice just
a little bit so they know
you need to furl your brow which i'm a
pro at right i got a i was born with a
furrow brow you could prefer your brow
elevate you know get your posture a
little bit more rigid so they can see
that you're not backing down raise your
voice and speak in very direct
tones
burke look you need to worry about your
part of the mission
and that like you said that shuts stuff
down
that's the frequency right there yeah
just right in there
right in there
it's interesting
just pid'd i just pid a thing right
i've been seeing that quite a bit lately
too
without a sharp and adaptable mind
the incompetent general succumbs to
cognitive dissonance rejecting or
ignoring unpalatable news or
intelligence
general arthur percival at singapore was
this type simply refusing to credit that
the japanese attack
his fortified island base we ran through
that on this podcast that guy's getting
reports hey the japanese are literally
surrounding us he's like they're not
going to attack
to explain the average general dixon has
to resort to ego psychology the average
general like so many average men and
women is trapped in the neurotic paradox
and here's the neurotic paradox the need
to be loved leads to twin quests for
admiration on the one hand
and power and fame on the other so you
want to be liked but you want to be
powerful since you got this thing going
on all the time naturally the two quests
collide violently
more power means that more people
dislike or envy you the great leaders
rise above the paradox by performing
competently and taking praise promotion
and criticism in mature measured stride
like like kipling's ideal man
they quote meet with triumph and
disaster and treat those two impostors
just the same
but most of dixon's subjects and the
reason
look dixon concentrates on the bad so
that's when he says most of dixon subs
he concentrates on the bad he doesn't
concentrate on the good leaders there's
plenty of books about good leaders out
there
most of dixon subjects like most of our
own are not great but merely ordinary
weak and often petty hence the need to
understand and apply the psychological
component of history
dixon's book is in two parts the first
presents the case studies the second the
psychological behaviors such as snobbery
and
anti-effeminacy which contribute to
institutional langur
in every man and earthy hungry id
battles with an intelligent tactful ego
overseen by a watchful superego this is
good man dixon writes is basically a
battlefield a dark cellar
in which a well-bred spinster lady and a
sex-crazed monkey are forever engaged in
mortal combat the struggle being
refereed by a rather nervous bank clerk
that's what's going on in your head
this is the fate of every human
excellence mediocrity or incompetence
hinge on how smoothly the monkey the
spinster and the bait clerk settled
their differences
reading about older wars one might
suppose that modern times deliver more
modern officers
that the victorian parenting and grimm
public schools that form dixon's case
studies are relics of an irrelevant past
not true
american parenting and high schools have
apparently contributed no less to
military incompetence consider the
record
in world war one general john blackjack
pershing had to fire two american corps
commanders six division commanders and
1400 brigadiers colonels and other
officers for incompetence this was
remarkable carnage considering that
america fought for just six months in
that war damn
george c marshall who served as a
colonel on pershing staff in world war
one and then presided over the us army
in world war ii as chief of staff was
anything but incompetent marshall was in
many ways the modern the model general
sound and mind and body he wrote in 1920
that an ideal officer
was of quote the optimistic and
resourceful type quick to estimate with
relentless determination and possessed
in addition a fund of sound common sense
which opera operated to prevent gross
errors due to rapidity of decision and
action
for hague optimism and that's the world
war one general for hague optimism had
been an abstract and silly concept
the spiritual willingness to always to
attack for martial it was a human
concept
the spiritual inclination to see a glass
is half full to find a way around
difficulties
and win in spite of them that's a big
difference
hague thinks optimism is you just go
marshall optimism is you figure out a
way to win
it's a big freaking difference
you've been warning people for a little
while now and i've been stealing this
about
the idea of lessons learned actually
being a problem there's some risk in
there as we
fight against bias you've talked about
bias on underground you talk about bias
in a lot of different ways and certainly
on the leadership consultancy side when
we're talking to people about ways to
make sure that you don't run into
problems in the future lessons learned
can actually contribute
to
making mistakes in the future because
you will pull these lessons thinking
somehow that it it sort of predetermines
the next outcome if the situation's the
same we know what the lessons are we
going to apply those lessons we're going
to control the outcome
and there's a little part of me just
really struggling to hear hearing you
read this
and yes there's some hindsight being
applied here but but
how do you look at world war one
and reflect on that and say
we won yeah when you when you like
barely didn't lose
and you could play semantics all day
long yes i know we won compared to the
germans who lost but in a sense that
this is a
this is a validation of the tactics that
we input this is a this is it the lesson
learned of what we did work because we
won and the idea that we can take that
and capture this as a as a reinforcement
that the things that we did were the
right things that's why we were
successful and setting in stone
again there's a lot of hindsight here i
understand that
looking forward if nobody knew in 1919
what was going to happen in 19 you know
the 1940s there was
we have that understanding now but even
in that time how do you look at that war
and reinforce that what we did was the
right thing when you're on the quote
winning side
it's insane it's insane
we won yeah we won wrong let's do it
again
yeah that's one of my favorite uh
sarcastic favorite jiu jitsu coaching
calls is oh carrie that arm locks not
working do it harder i've heard it i've
heard it
marshall also insisted on flexibility of
mind to nullify authoritarian tendencies
he blocked the rise of time servers
and other mediocrities marshall called
them calamity howlers for the way they
exaggerated difficulties and spun
excuses for their failures and noted
that such leaders inexorably demoralized
their units and infected them with
negativity
man
exaggerating your difficulties
of the 42 senior generals who took part
in the u.s army's last maneuvers before
pearl harbor only 11 would command units
in combat in world war ii that's
freaking savage
that is savage they were firing some
people
the rest had to be fired or sidetracked
as dead wood dozens of american generals
would lose their posts in the course of
the war
to officer an american army
that expanded 35-fold in three years
marshall put every candidate through his
paces shifting them into ever more
burdensome and pressure-packed jobs
promoting those who excelled those who
fail mostly grimly noted are out at the
first sign of faltering
which is interesting to me i thought i
immediately thought to myself oh so
that's zero zero defect right so now
we're scared but then
it doesn't say failing it says faltering
it means when the time to step up came
you might have made a bad decision okay
well you're okay but if you falter
you're out later that's a huge
difference
maybe i'm reading a little bit too much
into that but i'll go with it
it's a pretty specific word to choose
there though yeah walter right now
not fail not you know
marshall was the exception who proved
the rule by 1944 and 1945 the united
states enjoyed massive superiority over
the germans and men tanks guns and
aircraft yet plotted into germany the
dynamism of 1941 to 1943 when deutsche
eisenhower and marshall had pruned the
dead wood and shot younger officers up
the ladder was replaced with an emphasis
on methodical teamwork that would
harness america's material superiority
it was
like war by general motors with a
risk-averse corporate strategy more
concerned not to lose than to win
swiftly this was precisely the attitude
that shaped the post-war u.s army and
korea in korea and vietnam officers
could no longer be relieved for cause as
that would generate embarrassing
publicity and congressional inquiries so
they were often left in their jobs
70 year old douglas macarthur who
commanded the korean war from tokyo
possessed every trait of dixon's most
encourageable authoritarian and
committed every possible error nearly
precipitating an american defeat and
world war iii in vietnam general william
westmoreland's disastrous leadership was
initially viewed with great hope westie
succeeded a string of incompetents who
had misconstrued the war and given the
south vietnamese relentlessly bad advice
on how to win
first samuel hanging sand will hanging
sam williams then lieutenant colonel or
sorry then lionel split head magar
then paul
harkins the last derided by defense
secretary robert mcnamara as quote not
worth a damn westmoreland was supposed
to be different
but he proved the perfect military
incompetent dim
blinkered unsure of himself lost and
unmoored as a commander
he had actually refused to hire vince
lombardi as coach of the army football
team when he was superintendent of west
point in 1960 quote this was not the
kind of man i wanted around cadets westy
said of lombardi
his game plan in vietnam would be no
shrewder
one might ask how it could be otherwise
the vietnam war was directed by a
particularly vexing incompetent general
maxwell taylor the ultimate pleaser who
as presidential military adviser
chairman of the joint chiefs of staff
and then ambassador of south vietnam
flattered first john f kennedy and then
linden john lennon b johnson into
believing that they could eat their cake
and have it too that is fight the
vietnam war with limited means and
public support and still win it and i
read that not great limited means
and public support he's saying limited
means and limited public support and
still win it
like the military and civilian advisors
gathered around george w bush in 2003
taylor was obsessed with white house
access and was willing to suppress
conflicting opinions to conceal
stubborn facts to keep it that way
on the ground in saigon westmoreland
rather too eagerly brought taylor's
fraudulent talking points to life
and westy after all was just the sort of
average joe who got his ticket punched
in the u.s army of the 1960s he'd never
been to staff or war college only to a
cooks and baker's school and then a
13-week management course at harvard
he never read so harvard business school
formed him into a mcnamara-like
organization man all charts and graphs
that powerpoint general avant-la letra
i don't know what the letter i mean i
had to look that up means he was a
powerpoint general before there was such
a thing as a powerpoint general
literally means before the letter
his search and destroy strategy was an
unmitigated disaster not
least because of the destroying went on
in the south not in the north of vietnam
westy doggedly shelled bombed burned and
poisoned hundreds of villages succeeding
mainly in increasing the number of
insurgents and losing support of the
south vietnamese people the united
states dropped twice as many bombs on
allied south vietnam vietnam
as on the enemy north
more bombs in fact that have been
dropped in all theaters in world war ii
westmoreland's mantra was firepower
like dixon's incompetence he hid in the
only thing that he an artillery man knew
a man intending to lose a war could
hardly have done it with more efficiency
that's a freaking rough assessment
the fact that his civilian commanders
were no more acute in their judgment in
no way excused his incompetent strategy
he was relieved in 1968.
the iraq war reprised the vietnam
incompetence
with the
incurious unassertive tommy frank
succeeded by
general ricardo sanchez who
one historian labeled the william
westmoreland of the iraq war sanchez had
leaped from division to army command and
was the embodiment of the peter
principle
as a state department onlooker said of
him all trees no forest not a strategic
or political thought
when general david petraeus took over in
2007 he introduced effective counter
insert counter insurgency strategy but
too late to prevent the dissolution of
iraq into sectarian fragments or to
buttress plummeting american support for
the war senator chuck hagel asked the
marvelously prophetic question about
petraeus's troop surge quote what if the
what is the point of bringing the
violence down
with u.s troops if it will merely resume
once the u.s troops are withdrawn
hegel had served as a grunt in vietnam
he knew military folly when he saw it
nixon's detailed case
study ends in 1944 but he has a go at
more recent history in the last chapter
surveying the martial lunacy of vietnam
and the struggle the staggering
irrationality of the bay of pigs
invasion clearly implying
that there is no end
of military incompetence
and indeed the military ineptitude
displayed in the decades since vietnam
most shatteringly in the iraq war shows
that military incompetence and its
psychological roots cry out for
continued study and application this
book is a template and deserves its
classic reputation on this psychology of
military incompetence is also a vital cl
corrective
to what we are experiencing today
the uncritical adoration of veterans
troops and their officers by the
american public and more ominously by
presidential candidates in congress
living as we do in an age of nonstop
semi-war
the need for clear unsentimental
thinking is more important than ever it
has become routine for candidates
running for commander-in-chief to
describe their global strategies thus
quote i would check with my generals and
follow their advice end quote
dixon jerks us back to reality with our
civic responsibilities
what if the general or admiral is an
incompetent authoritarian blind to the
true situation leading the country into
a ditch what if the general is a
well-masked authoritarian type who
cannot learn from experience who denies
rationalizes deflects blame and creates
scapegoats the last usually quote the
folks in washington
indeed
what deficient american commander has
not made this his swan song quote
at least in blank i knew who the enemy
was here in washington i don't end quote
a failed iraq war commander was the last
to try that wheeze an old perennial that
bloomed during korea and vietnam too
read this book absorb its lessons and
you will be on your guard against this
infantilization
to revere the uniform without first
peering inside
indeed dixon cites a path-breaking swiss
child psychologist in this regard quote
the adult who is under the dominion of
unilateral respect for the elders
and for tradition
is really behaving like a child
that was just the forward of this book
uh that's jeffrey walrow
and this he wrote that in 2016 or that's
when this edition is
i got an older edition too you know i
got the old school hardcover one because
you know that's how i roll because i
know when we when we when this podcast
comes out people can go out and buy
those those old school ones i've already
got mine i tried to get as many off as i
could off the market
we roll into now into dixon's preface
and he starts this off and i probably
could have i probably could have and
probably should have started off this
whole podcast with this note that he
makes out of the gate he says this book
is not an attack upon the armed forces
no upon the nor upon the vast majority
of senior military commanders who in
time of war succeed in tasks which would
make the running of a large commercial
enterprise seem like child's play by
comparison so
i should have started the podcast with
that because let's face it
they're going to go hard in the paint
we're already feeling that
and it can be very easy to think that
any critique of
the leadership of these wars or
people in leadership positions
specifically
it can be very easy to interpret this as
shots at those people but
really and i think this is what's going
to be done in the book too is it's going
to be
more a breaking down of these um
leadership you know failing leadership
tactics and and you know leadership
roles or you know how these guys are
doing it more so than these guys
themselves you know what i mean am i
clothes there
unfortunately not no dixon
dixon goes harder than paint he's just
straight calling these guys out these
guys are gonna get called out okay well
based on his note there in the preface
it sounded like he was gonna go a little
different but he's going hard
yeah he goes hard he goes hard there's
no punches bro
and but he but and he doesn't spend as
much time he does he does talk about
some of the good military leaders
but he spends most of his time talking
about the bad military leaders right and
how just bad they were and why they were
bad and the mistakes that they made and
it wasn't like well you know he was
really making a good decision based on
the information he had it's like no
no he wasn't right he was you know we're
going to get some stories that make you
sick to your stomach some of these
stories will make you sick to your
stomach and and you know dixon served in
world war ii dixon was wounded right
this guy knows what's up he's probably
had some incompetent leaders
so
he's going to go hard but
and look i served with
incredible leaders in the military
incredible leaders
incredible
individual i don't know if there could
be better leaders than some of the
leaders i served with the military
so this book isn't an attack on the
armed forces or all leaders neither am i
and that's not what we're doing here
but
there are some bad seeds
and
we need to learn from that
because there's some legit things you
can do to take corrective measures and
watch out for this especially if just
like everything else if you aim this
book it yourself
if you aim this book yourself
and you every time i hear a for every
time i say authoritarian theme instead
of thinking like about your boss or
about some subordinate leader that you
have if you instead think oh
how am i authoritarian because that
doesn't oh i do that
oh i lean in that direction if you start
thinking like that right now that's
that's the benefit
that's what you should be trying to do
pretty much wiped out half my page of
notes here
did i just did i just jack your notes no
that's legit man i kept i you know like
i've said this a thousand times i get
the coolest part about being on this
podcast is i hear the stuff
in person live for the first time did
you order this book when i told you you
ordered it like a year ago yes we but
you've been sending me screenshots of
like you've been dabbling with this
thing for a while i've known this
thing's coming so it's cool
but
it's still mostly brand new like
this is all new and i get to write stuff
down
and
part of it is try to think about how
this makes sense in my own head and i
wrote down like five minutes ago there's
a lot of risk with this book
and the risk as i'm listening to you is
that it's going to be a validation for
the listeners that there's a bunch of
other screwed up people out there and
they're the problem
of the other people the other people
yeah and when i wrote down i go you
mitigate that risk by this by assuming
this guy is talking to you
not about other people he's talking
about
you
and the risk that you are a reflection
of those behaviors the only thing i
wrote down that
that i was thinking about in sort of
anticipation of this is that it's not
just these individuals
as flawed as they are and i'm glad that
we are
i'm glad all of us are taking a minute
to go hey listen this is not just us
taking shots at all these people in the
military to be be critical of them
because leading is hard the military is
hard and there's a whole bunch of
reasons
but there are flawed individuals the
other piece that compounds that for this
which is again something we can all
think about is that there is a system
that promotes that that validates that
that reinforces that it helps create and
take the worst of these behaviors and
magnify them
and
does your company does your team does
your family does your household does
your
business
do the exact same thing yeah and just to
add one more little thing that that you
said which is 100 right you're right the
military can in many ways
take these
people with these tendencies and promote
them it can do that it also even prior
to that attracts these people because
you know the authoritarian person likes
likes um things to be controlled
likes uniformity
you know if you're if you're uh
in college and you like uniformity and
you're looking at your your dorm room
going gosh i wish everyone would just be
quiet at night you're like oh you don't
want to join them i'm going to join the
military yeah the idea of rank to that
person exciting you mean you mean to
tell me yeah i put this on and people
will listen people will listen to me
they'd have to do what i say i'm in oh
the idea of uniformity is not a bad
thing it's a it's an attractiveness that
we literally wear a
uniform
that attribute is a positive in so many
ways for those of us interested in the
military so just to both of what you're
saying that idea like oh those things
you go man i don't want a bunch of yes
men uniform thinking you know uh uh
group think actually uniformity is
hailed as a positive attribute in many
ways across the military so much so like
100 the more you look like the person
next to you the better you are yes hey
that uniform looks exactly like this
regulation you're my guy yeah you think
about who's getting attracted to this
look do you get guys
men and women that are patriotic men and
women that want to challenge men and
women that want to take care of their
people and lead absolutely yeah
absolutely you do like you get all kinds
of do you get someone that just wants to
put that rank on and finally get
listened to lieutenant cali right
and nom they you know you read the
backstory on lieutenant cali from the
from the me lie massacre it's like oh he
was
no one respected him in his life he had
to go through ocs a bunch of times he
wanted that freaking rank so bad it was
probably like the most rewarding thing
he ever got
was to get that finally get that rank
and people just shut up and listen to me
so that's what you that's what you're
tracking so we are you doing that in
your company what kind of people are you
tracking into your company
scary
it is however an attempt to explain how
a a minority of individuals come to
inflict upon their fellow men depths of
misery and pain virtually unknown in
other walks of life that's a freaking
heavy sentence like that's true like hey
if you're in business and you're an
authoritarian okay cool you're gonna
you're gonna you're gonna drive some
people crazy whatever right you're in
the military you're causing
depths of misery and pain virtually
unknown in all other walks of life
this book involves the putting together
of contributions from a great many
people historian sociologists
psychologists and of course soldiers and
sailors it is hope that none of these
will feel misrepresented in the final
picture which their contributions make
for error is a fact
and for the opinions expressed i alone
take full responsibility okay he's
taking some owner ownership
in the writing of this book i also owe a
great debt of data to to gratitude to
all those who gave generously of their
time to reading and discussing earlier
drafts their encouragement criticisms
and advice have been invaluable and he
goes on to thank about a freaking page
and a half of people
names names names names
um
and then finally he gets to this port
for and and by the way one thing that's
interesting that you couldn't have
predicted is this guy's really funny
he's got that dry british humor humor
throughout the entire book and
he's awesome
so he brings the heat now you know you
carry he's like i'm sure he's not you
know taking oh he's taking shots not
only taking shots but some of them are
pretty damn funny yeah so he says this
he says
finally
i owe a debt of gratitude to that
handful of people who would probably
prefer to remain nameless whose
hostility and dismay that anyone should
write a book on military incompetence
provided considerable if unlooked for
confirmation of the relationship between
militarism and human psychopathology so
like all people like you shouldn't write
a book like exactly you're the reason
why i love that you are the reason why
so that's his opening
um now we get into chapter one like i
said this is gonna be a slow roll with
this book um
he starts off with a quote
at least it's a really short book yeah
klaus what's um
we only wish to represent things as they
are and to expose the error of believing
that a mere bravo without intellect can
make himself distinguished in war
and bravo can be used as a noun i found
out after reading that quote
means someone that's like
a daring man
gary man isn't good enough
by now most people have been have become
accustomed to
one might almost say blase about
military incompetence
like the common cold flat feet or the
british climate is accepted as part of
life
faintly ludicrous but quite unavoidable
surely there can be nothing left to say
about the subject he's coming out of the
gate look yeah military incompetence
whatever it's the way it is it's like
flat feet some people got it
in fact military incompetence is largely
preventable tragically expensive and
quite absorbing segment of human
behavior it also follows certain laws oh
that's a bold statement
the first
intimation of this
came to the writer during desultry
reading about notorious military
disasters these moving often horrific
accounts evoked a curious deja vu
experience for there was something about
these apparently senseless goings-on
which sent one's thoughts along new
channels making contact with phenomena
from quite other
hitherto unrelated contexts and then
back again to the senseless facts
not now quite so senseless until
gradually a theme continuous as a
hairline crack could be discerned
throughout the stirring tales of daring
dew that was a big sentence
what's he saying in that what he's
saying is he started reading about all
these military disasters and as he read
them he would think about another one
and you think about another one and what
he started to see was a thread that
connected them all together
if this pattern was real and it meant
what it seemed to mean certain
predictions would follow these were
tested and found correct yet other
pieces began falling into place until
gradually the mosaic of elements took on
the semblance of a theory this book is
about that theory it is concerned with
placing aspects of military behavior in
the context of general psychological
principles
this sounds fine a cheerful marriage of
history and psychology unfortunately
however such a union may not be entirely
agreeable to some of potential in-laws
judging from the attitude of some
historians putting together of
psychology and history is to say the
least bad form while putting together of
psychology and military history is
positively indecent there are at least
two reasons for this anxiety the first
is that since there are few things more
annoying than having one's behavior
explained there exists a natural
distaste for explanations of historical
figures with who with whom one perhaps
identifies so he's saying look i'm gonna
write this book it's about psychology
and it's about military history and
that's not gonna be popular
because a lot of people
relate to those military figures those
historical military figures and when you
start talking about why they made those
decisions some people are going to get
offended by that
so that's the first reason why this is a
risky book
the second reason is a distrust of
reductionism
of the idea that anything so complex as
a military disaster could possibly be
reduced to explanations in terms of the
workings of the human mind
and this by a psychologist of all people
so are you going to tell me all this
stuff took place and it was because of
this dude you know had a weird
psychology about something that's what
we're gonna say
in answer one can only say that has of
course historians know more about
history
than do psychologists
of course historical events are
determined by a complex set of variables
political economic geographical
climactic sociological but ultimately
history is made by human beings
and whatever other factors may have
contributed to a military disaster one
of these was the minds of those who were
there
and another the behavior to which these
minds gave rise
so there's all kinds of things that are
playing into these disasters and yes
uh uh the the climate and the g the
geography and the economics all those
things are playing into it
but you also had these human beings
minds
and how did their minds end up that way
now these are complex variables
hence it has been necessary to play down
the other factors in order to focus more
clearly upon the psychological
determinants
consider
the analyst case of aircraft accidents
dave burke glad you're here
nobody would deny that aeroplanes crash
for a number of different reasons
sometimes
working independently sometimes in
unison but this does not mean that the
selecting out for particular study of a
single factor such as metal fatigue
necessitates dwelling on other such
variables as bad weather in different
navigation
or too much alcohol in the bloodstream
of the pilot
so just because the the pilot was drunk
doesn't mean you can't look at the metal
fatigue that it put on the wings
the case for a reductionist approach
however also rests upon other
considerations namely that the nature of
military incompetence and those
characteristics which distinguish
competent from incompetent senior
commanders have shown a significant lack
of variation over the years despite
changes in other factors which shaped
the course of history so
you see failure failure failure failure
all these different failures and there's
been
a lack of variation
of what caused the failures from a
psychological perspective even though
the factors uh the the environment has
totally changed so it's not like well
you know you had horses and so
but you failed and you had tanks and you
failed wait a second what's the common
thread oh the mind
whether they are well equipped or
ill-equipped whether they are in control
of men who are armed with spears or
tanks or rockets whether they are
english russian german zulu american or
french good commanders pretty much
remain the same
likewise bad commanders have much in
common with the other which is what we
say all the time sometimes we'll get
asked a question well you know uh
what makes
what makes this type of person a good
leader it's like it doesn't matter what
it doesn't matter if they're a frontline
infantry leader or a
financial consultant company or a
construction company the leadership
characteristics that make the good
leaders are all the same yeah humble
leaders usually do better no matter the
situation it's ridiculous
one reward rewarding byproduct of
writing this book has been the many
enjoyable conversations i've had with
people are in the armed services here
again however
a small minority viewed the enterprise
with dismay as something lacking in
taste if not actually boarding on sac
religious so he's having conversations
with people telling he's going to write
this book and they're like oh
why are you going to do
that he got a little footnote here it
says it is fair to add that certain
common characteristics of those
civilians and servicemen who took
extreme view provided a very useful clue
as to the possible origins of military
incompetence
yes
sacrilege
you should not write a book like that
okay
to this understandable sensitivity i can
only say
that no insult is intended and point of
fact for the devotees of the military to
take exception to a study of military
incompetence
is as unjustified as it would be for
admirers of teeth to complain about a
book on dental caries
which means decay
in an imperfect world the activities of
professional fighters are presumably as
necessary to society as those of police
prostitutes sewage disposers and
psychologists it is just because we
cannot do without these callings except
possibly the last that any serious
attempt to understand the peculiarities
should be welcomed and indeed taken as a
compliment
for the token of their importance that
we should merit such attention so we're
freaking it
you've got to be kidding me
why wasn't this book why isn't there
just like decades of these books being
written for every
situation every war that's taken place
moreover is only
by contemplation of the incompetent that
we can appreciate the difficulties and
accomplishment of the competent if there
were no incompetent generals it might
appear that the direction of armies and
the waging of war were easy tasks well
within the compass of all who had the
good fortune to reach the highest levels
of military organizations however it is
not only when contrasted with the inept
that great commanders look their best
but also when seen in context of the
organizations to which they belong the
thesis will be developed that the
possibility of incompetence springs in
large measure from the unfortunate if
unavoidable side effects of creating
armies and navies this is to your point
earlier dave we create these things and
they kind of produce or at least have a
tendency to produce incompetence and
therefore when you're a good leader
inside of a organization that produces
incompetence you're actually doing
double good you get two gold stars
for the most part these tend to produce
a leveling down of human capability at
once encouraging to the mediocre but
cramping to the gift but cramping to the
gifted
viewed in this light those who had
performed brilliantly in the carrying of
arms may be considered twice blessed
i guess i just stole that from him for
they achieved success despite
bad features of the organization to
which they
happen to belong this alone would seem
to justify an unabashed excursion to the
realms of military incompetence but
there are additional grounds if anything
more pressing they
they concern the related issues of cost
and probability
while few would dispute that the cost
grows
exponentially with the growth of
technology so that the price of wrong
decisions must now be reckoned in mega
deaths
the chance of military incompetence
remains a matter for debate we might
hope that this would be a declining
function for better education more
realistic values greater fear of
immeasurably worse consequences and an
increa decrease in jingoism
but there are strong grounds for taking
the pessimistic view
that the chance like the cost continues
to increase with positive acceleration
this is getting worse is what he's
saying hey don't you think hey look if
you're going to go out and you're going
to fight with swords
and you're a bad leader you're probably
going to get
50 guys killed
now you're going to go out and fight
with artillery and machine guns now
you're gonna get a thousand people
killed we must be making improvement
we're not
in fact it's getting worse
several reasons may be advanced for this
depressing hypothesis
firstly the gap between the capabilities
of the human mind and the intellectual
demands of modern warfare continues that
expansion which started in the 18th
century it is probably opening from both
sides while modern war becomes
increasingly swift and deadly and the
means by which it is waged increasingly
complex the intellectual level of those
entering the armed services as officers
could well be on the wane
ouch he wrote this in 1976 just saying
he's like hey if you're going to the
military right now you know
this tentative supposition is based on
the fact that fewer and fewer of the
young consider the military to be a
worthwhile career again this is post nom
he's writing this one has only to look
at the contemporary recruiting
advertisements to realize the evident
difficulties of finding officer material
they spare nothing in their efforts to
convince
an unresponsive youth
the services are depicted as glittering
toy shops where handsome young men enjoy
themselves with tanks and missiles while
basking in the respective lower ranks
hardly less godlike than themselves
in their eagerness to drum up applicants
these calls to arms attempt the mental
contortion of presenting the services of
a classless society in which officers
nevertheless remain gentlemen
the clear clear implica
implication of such expensive pleading
can surely be that the market for a
military career is shrinking to say the
least
to meet this fall off in officer
recruitment if
insufficient has been done in the
writer's opinion to improve the real
as opposed to the advertised incentive
value of military care again this is
written in the 70s
so
you didn't have long lines at the
recruiting offices
in 1973 when he was writing this you can
see how one might have this outlook on
the military during that time for sure
yeah um
skip a little bit here in short possibly
less able people are being called upon
to carry out a more difficult cost task
with a heavier price tag
and the highest levels
of responsibility which are staggering
in the vietnam war alone the military
commanders were responsible for
executing policies which cost the united
states 300 billion dollars
seems cheap now coming out of
afghanistan a two trillion dollar price
tag they were responsible for releasing
13 million tons of high explosives more
than six times the weight of bombs
dropped by the united states in all
theaters during the whole of the second
world war they were responsible for the
delivery of 90 000 tons of gas and
herbicides and they were responsible for
the deaths of between 1 and 2 million
people
these are great responsibilities errors
of generalship on this scale would be
very costly of course many of the
arguments put forward in this book are
equally applicable to other human
enterprises
that's why we're freaking interested in
this stuff
indeed there is no reason to suppose
that incompetence occurs more frequently
in military subcultures than it does in
politics commerce or the universities
there are however apart from the heavy
cost of military disasters special
reasons for studying cases of military
ineptitude so this applies to everywhere
that's why i mean this is what we do for
a living in echelon from this is what we
do for a living
but
he's going to call out the reasons why
he's going to focus on the military the
first is that military organizations
have a particularly propensity
for attracting a minority of individuals
who might prove a menace at high levels
of command and the second is that the
nature of militarism serves to
accentuate those very traits which might
ultimately prove disastrous which is
what we just talked about
dave burke likes people to listen to him
and he realizes there's a place he can
go he can put a freaking gold bar on his
collar and he becomes the man
in theory then errors of generalship
could be prevented by attention to these
causes you would think
thirdly
the public has at least in the
democracies
some real say as to who should make its
political decisions this does not apply
to generals so look we get to vote you
out
if you're a president
or you're a senator or you're a
representative we can vote you out can't
vote on a general chairman of a board
you know you look at businesses you know
anything like that not the case here
yeah we can fire you from your position
even the worst government and the most
inept prime minister could come up for
possible dismissal every so often this
is not true of armies and navies we have
we may have the governments
we deserve but sometimes
had the military minds which we did not
fourthly if one of the main differences
between military and political
organization
organizations is the degree of public
control
that
between the military and commerce lies
in decision payoffs
and he's got this note here so
relatively trivial and unimportant our
most academic decisions that it would be
arrogant to discuss them in the same
breath
this guy takes shots at the academia
quite a bit
for a guy that's a freaking
professor or he was a professor
a wrong decision by a company chairman
or board of directors may cost a great
deal of money and depress a sizable
population of shareholders but military
errors have cost hundreds of thousands
of lies lives and untold misery to
civilians and soldiers alike but the
case for a study of military
incompetence rests upon other issues not
the least of these is the need to
examine a view of military behavior
diametrically opposed to though in no
way less extreme than that of people who
would vehemently defend senior
commanders against even the faintest
breath of criticism well this is what i
was talking about earlier we think oh
this guy was in the military
so he must be squared away
no
this other hypocritical stance seems
remarkably widespread thus for many
people with whom the author discrust
discussed a central topic of this book
the notion of military incompetence
struck as an immediate and responsive
cord rejoinders range from you will have
no shortage of data to surely that's the
whole of military history so when he
told people who's gonna write this book
they go oh yeah you got plenty of data
on incompetence and isn't that just the
entire military history
but when pressed for details there was a
tendency to become vague and retire
behind a 1066 and all that attitude
to the subject psychological causes were
usually reduced to a single factor low
intelligence or as one historian put it
the bloody fool theory of military
history so look you got people that made
bad decisions they were stupid
doubtless this view has
been contributed to by such books on
military ineptitude as alan clark's the
donkeys an abrasive critique of the
generals of the first world war
certainly its title taken from the
famous conversation between ludenhirff
ludendorff and hoffman and such captions
as donkey decorates alliance so this
book the donkeys this is a quote that
you got you guys ever heard the quote
lions led by lambs
so here's the original quote according
to the memoirs of field marshal vaughn
falkenheim
cited by alan clark field marshall van
ludendorf's comment the english soldiers
fight like lions
was greeted by his friend major general
max hoffman with true but don't we know
they are lions led by donkeys
and they got a picture in this book of
you know some general giving a
young soldier an award and the caption
is donkey decorates lion
the contents of this book imply however
that while stupidity may have possibly
played a part limited intelligence was
certainly not the cause of the behavior
for which the generals have been
criticized judging from the spate of
books among which the donkey the donkeys
appeared it looked as if the taboo had
been lifted on peering into the military
woodshed
but
mixing our rural metaphors the ernst
while sacred cows were once more being
transmogfied
into
nothing more than very unsacred asses
transmogrified had to look that word up
what is that it means magically change
that magically changed so
transmorgified thus one historian has
ascribed a series of military mishaps to
bone-headed leadership another spoke of
quote the long gallery of military
imbecility while a third has said of
british soldiers that their fate was
decided for them by idiots
so that's what they're normally you know
this guy was just stupid
and as you read this as you read this
book you realize these are smart people
in many cases and that's such a
dismissive take
on that you know it's just like oh that
guy was dumb you know it
yeah yeah that's exactly the point he's
making right is oh oh yeah the guy was
just stupid
you you and and you know what's funny is
how often do you
how often did you hear throughout your
life oh yeah that guy's smart has no
common sense right that's like a common
thing oh that guy's oh they'll say oh
he's really book smart which is a
a dig
right
it doesn't matter how smart you are if
you can't make good decisions and these
people are actually smart in many cases
the view taken here is that besides
being unkind these views are probably
invalid the hypothesis of intellectual
intellectual incapacity leaves two
questions quite unanswered how if they
are so lacking intelligence do people
become senior military commanders which
is an accurate statement i mean you
can't be a senior military commander if
you're stupid
maybe maybe occasionally and what is it
about military organizations that they
should attract promote and ultimately
tolerate those whose performance at the
highest levels may
destroy the organizations that they
represent to answer those these
questions however it is first necessary
to discover what the job of generalship
entails and how it could be done so
badly or so well
this the bare bones of good and bad
generalship is examined in the next
chapter in terms of information theory
okay you know as i was going through
this book trying to decide what you know
what i'm going to read i just had to go
hard in these first couple chapters to
lay down
um
the background the context and so it's
almost like all that right there
is starting to head towards what we're
talking about
the main part of this book is divided
into two halves the first is concerned
with case histories examples of military
ineptitude over a period of some hundred
years or so much of this material will
no doubt be all too familiar to the
reader it is included here and the
selections made with two main purposes
in mind to provide an aid memoria
and because it is believed that common
denominators of military incompetence
emerge most clearly when looked at in a
longitudinal study
one special virtue of this approach is
that the highlights it highlights the
influence or more often regret
regrettable lack of influence
of earlier
upon later events so throughout he's
covering these histories and as you
cover these histories
you can see that there's just nothing
learned
you know it's even
i guess maybe worse or at least the same
ballpark as you're talking about dave oh
they took these lessons learned and they
made them rigid and just as bad as that
is we just didn't learn anything
for the most part
cases of incompetence have been taken
from british military history far from
being unpatriotic this apparently
one-sided approach springs from a
sentimental regard for the cross forces
of the crown
whose record of valor and fighting
ability is second to none and whose
ability to rise above the most intense
provocation either from a civilian
population as in northern ireland today
or from the lapses of their top
leadership in days gone by must surely
occupy a unique position in the history
of warfare so he's like hey i'm going to
talk about the brits
nothing against the brits in fact the
brits have the
unbelievable history
but that's what we're going to look at
the second half of the book is devoted
to discussion
and explanation it is subdivided into
two parts the first concern with the
social psychology of military
organizations and the second with the
psychopathology of individual commanders
and what's i'm telling you
i was like oh well maybe i'll just do
this maybe i'll just do that maybe let's
do one part
it the context is so strong
and he doesn't play around he doesn't he
doesn't wait until the end to start
explaining things he's doing it
throughout the book
so
and and as you said and as i said you
know you got to aim this book yourself
man it's uncomfortable sometimes you're
reading this thing and you're like oh
oh man
like oh i did that i did this you know
you can feel it
the approach here is essentially
eclectic drawing upon
ethological
psychoanalytic and behaviorist theories
it attempts to explain military
ineptitude in light of five inescapable
if unfortunate features of human
psychology
these are
one
man shares with lower animals certain
powerful instincts and again these are
like the root
of what he's talking about
these five inescapable
parts of our brains
so we share with lower animals certain
powerful instincts two unlike lower
animals most men learn to control
frustrate direct and sublimate
these instinctual energies
so
right we got control over some of these
things at least we're supposed to we can
at least frustrate them that's a good
word right we can at least frustrate
them
three
while by far the largest part of this
learning occurs in early childhood its
effects upon adult personality are
profound and long-lasting again this is
where you know you get into like uh you
know freud and how you're raised and all
these little things that are in your
childhood and i don't know if that's
right or wrong i don't know if that's
right or wrong because i think i've seen
people that have been raised all kinds
of different ways and end up all kinds
of different ways
but i think the end result is you end up
with a personality regardless of where
it comes from you end up with a certain
personality or certain personal
personality aspects that we can pid we
can identify them
four residues of this early learning and
in particular unresolved conflicts
between infantile desires and the
demands
of punitive morality may remain wholly
unconscious yet provide a canker of
inexhaustible anxiety
again
really tying our behaviors to what how
we got treated when we were kids and if
you got
you know
the room had to be clean you had to
clean your plate like all those little
things and again chiming if you guys
think i'm wrong i've known people that
were raised in a totally strict
environment and they end up on one end
of the spectrum and i've known people
that raised in a totally strict
environment they end up in a totally
different person
are there some root things that are
overlapping sure but i think we have to
look
and maybe it's just the way
psychologically things play out
you know but
they're there does he say unresolved
yes so i think that has i think that
word jumps out at me
the unresolved part i think
i think a lot of times people are able
to come to terms with something from
their childhood and and then
own it right move past it um i think
it's the unresolved part that lingers
right where there's still
there's a bit of broken something there
that hasn't been addressed and because
of that it continues to plague the
individual as they try to move forward
so maybe if i know you two and you both
were raised you know in this super
strict way and yet carrie was like you
know what you know my my mom was just a
little bit crazy and that's cool
and but dave was like
they couldn't let it go
maybe that's what makes dave you know a
little bit a little bit a little bit
harder in that respect or maybe you're
both raised by you know the hippie
parents that didn't care and you know
carrie was like yeah i don't need to
care about anything it's all good and
dave was like you know i don't want to
end up like that you end up with a
more
militaristic mindset or a trauma hippie
mom wrecks the van mm-hmm
johnny
moves on you know yeah
dave doesn't
dave
dave bears the scar right
this thing hidden close to home to you
man what's going on here
in the sky i'm just saying
yeah
i really do i think he doesn't wreck the
van
all right uh the last one when this
anxiety becomes the driving force in
life's endeavors the fragile edifices of
reason and competence are placed in
jeopardy so that's scary
again
regard for me regardless of the source
of this personality trait that you end
up with
it if that be it doesn't matter where it
came from
if you have it and it becomes the
driving force in your endeavors that's
where we run into a problem and
and i don't want to say it doesn't
matter where it came from but
regardless of what you think of that
we know someone that's
hyper e their ego is out of control like
it doesn't really matter
i shouldn't say it doesn't matter where
came from but there's nothing we can do
about where it came from but if i
understand that dave has a massive ego
i'm not sitting there going well you
know do i need to have him sit down on
the couch you know and like let's go
go go hypnotism and break down where he
got this giant ego from or am i like
okay he's got a big giant ego
how do i work through this how do i get
this you know how do i approach him with
ideas so
we can we can dwell on that a little bit
where these people how these people end
up like this and i think that is
important to an extent is just if you
can understand somebody a little bit
better you can maneuver better
but regardless they end up you end up
with these personalities
different personalities
oh my
i knew a guy
um
i mean i know you know there was a whole
slew because when i got in the navy
so it's 1990 this had to be similar for
you there's a whole slew of my friends
in the seal teams who parents were just
straight hippies just freaking hippies
like conceived at woodstock and whatever
like
just straight up hippies and
yet they took the most militaristic life
that they could
being a commando right so
how's that work
yeah
maybe it's a reaction to that you know
and vice versa have you ever known
someone that had that hardcore strict
religious upbringing and how do they end
up wild freaking maniac
you know i feel like that's the generic
go-to right where it's like the rebel
you know
came from that strict catholic school
you know whatever they just go yeah the
other way and it's weird because you
that's not neither one of these things
is like oh you went to a strict catholic
school now you're a rebel no there's
plenty of people that went to a catholic
school and they become strict catholics
so
that's i think this is why and again i'm
not a psychologist and i don't even know
enough about psychology but i'm saying
regardless of my opinion because that's
all it is an opinion
the result that you get is oh this
person has a very rebellious attitude
and he's in my platoon how do i deal
with him or this person has a massive
ego he's in my platoon
how do i deal with them
it says here in due course we shall
examine the scientific basis for these
propositions and their relevance to a
theory of military incompetence because
this is a book about incompetence rather
than competence about disasters rather
than successes these chapters may appear
to take an unnecessarily jaundiced view
of the military profession and to dwell
more upon what is bad rather than what
is good and man's attempts to
professionalize violence
but without teasing out
and enlarging upon the less pleasant
features
of a multi-faceted phenomenon there
could be no theory to account for those
human aberrations which have caused so
much unnecessary suffering as war
as klauswitz wrote of war
this is the way in which the matter must
be viewed and it is to no purpose
it is even against one's better interest
to turn away from the consideration of
the real nature of the affair because of
the horror of its elements
excites repungence so
we shouldn't not look at war just
because it's freaking savage
to the reader who recoils and discussed
from these chapters i can only say
that the theory they advance is based
upon the emergence of a pattern of which
each small piece may in itself seem
trivial possibly ludicrous even
obnoxious but which when put together
with other pieces begins to make sense
this interdependence
between the parts necessitates keeping
an open mind and however much one may
dislike or disbelieve the existence of
individual trees postponing judgment
until the wood is seen in its entirety
for the reader who is obsessed with
trees and thinks that history should be
left to historians ideas about
soldiering to soldiers and that
psychological theorizing should never go
below the belt this is the moment to
stop reading and save yourself some
irritation
we're rolling into chapter two
which is generalship
war is the province of uncertainty
three-fourths of those things upon which
action and war must be calculated are
hidden more or less in the clouds of
great uncertainty clausewitz
in a situation where the consequences of
wrong decisions are so awesome where a
single bit of irrationality can set a
whole train of traumatic events in
motion i do not think that we can be
satisfied with the assurance that quote
most people behave rationally most of
the time end quote
this this is a quote that i say to
clients all the time hey people are
crazy including you you've got to deal
with all these crazy people so assuming
that people are going to behave
rationally is a dumb thing to assume
and the additional layer that you
already talked about earlier is what's
rational to me
is not rational to you yeah so even my
expectations of what i think you would
do as you consider rationing like this
is a totally rational thing for me to do
and it's exactly opposite of what i
would do
which is crazy that you and i can have
those two
opposite views yep
but that's the reality
uh war is primarily concerned with two
sorts of activity the delivering of
energy and the communication of
information this is a crazy thing to
think about the delivering of energy
in war each side is kept busy by turning
its wealth into energy which is then
delivered free
gratis and for nothing to the other side
such energy may be muscular thermal
kinetic or chemical
wars are only possible because the
recipients of this energy are
ill-prepared to receive it and convert
it into useful form for their own
economy
if by means
of say impossibly large funnels and
gigantic reservoirs they could capture
and store the energy flung at them by
the other side the recipients of this
unsolicited gift would soon be rich
so and the other side so poor that
further warfare would be unnecessary for
them and impossible for their opponent
opponents
it's a very interesting way to
i've never heard it put that way
it's the truth right yeah it is creating
energy and hacking it at the other side
for free for free and only because they
can't handle it
unfortunately such levels of technology
have not been reached in the vietnam war
alone the united states delivered to
indochina enough energy to displace 3.4
billion cubic yards of earth 10 times
the amount dug out for the canals of
suez and panama combined
and enough raw materials in the shape of
fuels
metals and other chemicals to keep
several major industries supplied for
years in fact
apart from a little slum clearance this
abundance of energy was wasted consumed
in the making of 26 million craters
and laying waste of 20 000 square
kilometers of forest and the destruction
of enough crops to feed 2 million people
for a year
however while the reception of energy is
still totally uncontrolled this is
certainly not true of its direction and
delivery indeed these have become a
matter of some sophistication and the
prime concern of the military and naval
commanders there's the job of deciding
how when and where to dispose of the
energy which their side makes available
they do this by occupying nodal points
on a complex communication network
in other words the ideal senior
commander may be viewed as a device for
receiving processing and transmitting
information in a way which will yield
maximum gain for the minimum costs
whatever else he may be he is part of a
telephone exchange and part computer
these the common denominators of general
ship are depicted in figure one and now
he's got this figure here and this is uh
we're gonna go like a little bit of ooda
activity so dave can get all excited
he's got this first section which is
input this is what this is the input
that you're getting
you've got the program that you're on
the broad strategy the directives from
the government the orders from higher
military authority etc you've got
information about the enemy about your
own troops this includes strength
disposition morale intentions supplies
capabilities you've got miscellaneous
information weather forecast time of
year moon tides limitations of staff
communication map so you got all these
things that are you've got your input
now
the input that you get as a leader gets
pre-processed by the staff
the
what the staff is doing is they're
receiving it
they're putting it through it through a
decision process they're running it
through a program of their own previous
experience they got their memories how
good is their memory
and then you get this output
which eventually brings you results and
by the way that's a loop the whole time
so you got that's the decision thing
that's happening
you got information you're processing it
you're bouncing off your experiences
you're bouncing it off your
your uh staff
you run that loop until you figure out
what you should do which is pretty
straight which is seems complicated and
you already tell it'd be hard it's going
to be hard to make a really like a solid
decision and then you've got this other
section here which is called noise
and this is what this is what screws you
up
external enemy action inadequate
intelligence sources
deluded chief of staff
et cetera et cetera internal
defective senses or memory so those are
like you got all kinds we could list a
million things that are external that
are distractions and noise internal
you've got defective senses emotion
rigidity stretch stress dissonance
alcoholism neurosis there's all kinds of
things freaking you're a disaster
you're a disaster is what you are
so
he says so so i just kind of like
described what this diagram looks like
for those who don't relish in flow
diagrams let it suffice to say that on
the basis of a vast conglomerate of
facts to do with the enemy his own side
geography weather etc coupled with his
own long-term store of past experience
and specialist knowledge the senior
commander makes decisions that ideally
accord with the directives with which he
has been programmed ideally but these
ideals are hard to meet
for there are two main reasons the first
is the senior commanders often
have often to fill a number of
incompatible roles according to morris
janowitz these include include heroic
leader military manager and technocrat
so that's what you've got to do if
you're a leader in the military heroic
leader military manager and technocrat
to these we would add politician public
relations man and father figure and
psychotherapist because that's what
you're doing
the second reason for a breakdown is
what communication engineers call noise
in the system noise is what interferes
with the smooth flow of information its
destructive power hinges on the fact
that senior commanders like any other
device for processing information are
channels of limited capacity if they
want to deal with more information
they will tend to take longer about it
if they don't take longer they will make
mistakes here we are using the term
information in a special and perhaps its
most important sense
as the that which indeed reduces
uncertainty
so that's what information is
information is that which which reduces
uncertainty
let me expand on this a little
acquiring knowledge involves the
reduction of ignorance through the
acquisition of facts but ignorance is
rarely absolute and its reduction rarely
total doesn't matter you're not going to
know
everything and you're not going to know
nothing
hence reducing ignorance can be regarded
as reducing uncertainty about a given
state of affairs it follows that an
unlikely or unexpected fact contains
more information
i.e reduces more uncertainty than one
which is already expected
he's going to go into that hard
that what i just said it follows that an
unlikely or unexpected fact contains
more information
i.e reduces more uncertainty than one
which is already expected
we already expected it well it doesn't
really help me that much
but an unexpected fact is less readily
absorbed than one which was expected ooh
i wasn't expecting this to happen so i'm
going to kind of reject it
if this is less
than crystal clear consider the
following example cast in a suitability
suitable military context
the message in this case consists of an
intelligence report which states quote
enemy preparing for counter attack
attack end quote it goes on to detail
strength disposition date and likely
sector for attack
now this message factually so simple
contains amount of information
which differ greatly from commander to
commander
to general a
who anticipated such a counter attack it
conveys very little it merely confirms a
hypothesis which he already held
in fact since he had already made
extensive preparation for a
counter-attack the intelligence report
when it came was largely redundant
so that's general a hey i was expecting
this cool got it
in the case of general b however the
same message was quite unexpected so
little had he anticipated an enemy
counter-attack that the news was charged
with information it reduced a great deal
of ignorance and uncertainty
it gave him plenty to occupy his mind
and much to do
and i'm going to dive into that part
right there because this is really
important
finally we have general c for whom the
message was so totally unexpected that
he chose to ignore it with disastrous
results it conflicted with his
preconceptions it clashed with his
wishes it emanated so he thought from an
unreliable source
since his mind was closed to its
reception he found plenty of reasons for
refusing to believe it like british
generals after the battle of cambray or
american generals before the german
counter effect offensive in the ardans
of 1944 he ignored it at his cost
its information content was just too
high for his channel of limited capacity
and and so those three examples
and
when i when i first read this
i thought general a it doesn't contain
much information because he was already
expecting it general b got a lot of
information from it because he wasn't
expecting it and it seems like general b
might be in a better situation because
he was he got more information but
that's not true and it all boils down to
this last thing
its information content was too high for
his limited channel of cap capacity of
his limited uh
channel limited capacity
i think
an advantage
that i have
and that i try and teach other people
is to have an open mind and to and to
not when new information arises to to
absorb it and and accept it and be like
okay this is new information
i take it with a grain of salt of course
but i'm not
and and and go even further than that
it's not just that my mind is open it's
that i'm
i'm
actually trying to anticipate what's
going on i'm actually thinking well what
are they probably going to do you know
they're probably going to do this and
when but i don't dig in on that
you know the enemy could probably have
attacked from the west but i don't know
the enemy's going attack the enemies are
going to probably attack from the west
but they could also come from the south
and you know what they could come from
these north doesn't matter
i think that when you said the word
anticipation was the peace as i'm
hearing you talk about it
you hear those three generals and you
think oh b's the right guy oh you
thought that no no no no no no no no no
i i i don't i actually i'm i'm trying to
explain the logic
it seems at face value as it unfolded in
my head yeah yeah like oh i could see
people going oh b's the best example
because he got the most information oh
man this changes everything holy cow and
clearly sees the worse because he's like
i can't accept that in my brain so we're
not doing that i don't acknowledge it
and to his folly like it's gonna the
whole team's gonna get wiped out but
when you said anticipation because i
think of it as you've as we talk about
it as we teach it and as as you've
discussed it which is i'm going to do
these things i'm going to make these
moves i'm going to i'm going to try to
create a situation that unfold a certain
way but i know
i know
it doesn't go the way that i expect
which means i am anticipating
a bunch of other potential options now i
don't necessarily know which one it's
going to be but when you come back and
say it didn't go
let me say it differently it went this
way and no matter what this way is you
go okay i can see that i can see how our
moves created this outcome and maybe not
even what you want or maybe not even
what you expected
but the other ones aren't
unexpected
which makes it so much easier to go okay
cool now i've got the information here's
the adjustments we're going to make or
hey we'll continue down the path if it's
the way we wanted but the anticipation
that the outcome is not what you want
that word that's the piece for me that
resonates which is the best situation to
be in is oh it was different than i
wanted even a little different than i
expected and i'm not surprised by that
i don't get caught mentally off balance
very often because you don't
predetermine the outcome because i don't
i don't lean too hard now i'm not saying
i don't lean but i don't i don't lean so
much that when
that resistance isn't there i just fall
in my face yeah
and i i
i steal like a comment that you made
with from from your second platoon
commander over and over again the
context he was using it was someone on
his on your team doing something wasn't
really smart and it's just the simple
saying of you gotta expect these things
to happen but i overlay that onto
everything i can think of which is oh
that didn't really go as expected but
i'm not that surprised by it like yeah i
kind of expect these things to happen
and just the idea of saying
you gotta expect those things to happen
other people thinking
holy cow this is a level 10 emergency
this is a unsolvable tragedy he's like
no i i kind of am used to these type of
things going the way that people don't
expect and we can actually solve this i
can absorb it and make some changes no
factor yeah yeah
don't over commit to your brain over
commit the outcome the the other thing
about this example is
with this mechanical like dissection
he's doing of all this stuff
there's he talks a lot about the
capacity and with general a
you've got
very little capacity left over from what
you were expecting right so you've got
your expectation of what's going to
happen and you've got some capacity
left over to
to dedicate to what's actually happening
um guy b or the general b let's say um
he it takes him by surprise so now he
has to do so much more
back end work that general a's already
done and he's got all this free capacity
that now he can dedicate to what's
actually happening and the third guy has
got so little
you know that he just he's he's he
chooses to willfully ignore what's
happening rather than take on the
challenge of you know yeah if you did
one of those uh games where you have to
look at something for a short period of
time and remem remember as much as you
can if i said okay dave i'm gonna show
you a car in this next picture
it's a ford bronco and i want you to
remember as much about it as you could
you'd be like okay here's the caller
here's the license plate but if i said
hey carrie i want you to go and i'm
gonna show you a picture
tell me as much about it as you can you
you'd be like get half a quarter of the
information because you just don't have
that much your their capacity is already
taken
it's overflowing right with stuff trying
to make sense of the color right like
you're trying to figure all this out and
you're just overwhelmed so that's what
we're trying not to do right
and i think also too just from a
leadership standpoint when you're
thinking about people there aren't three
versions of people out there there's
seven billion versions of that so this
is a
is this is a dial across all those
spectrums and and certainly you can
categorize that and those examples are
good examples but even inside there you
don't just get three yeah if you got a
team of 26 you're not don't bend them
into three categories and presume they
sit in those bins i bet you
that you could probably break it down
into weight classes though
and not end up with seven billion but
end up with like nine
classes you know and it's really just
there's a spectrum inside there yeah for
sure like oh yeah you're between you
know 170 pounds and 185 pounds like we
know what kind of we know you're like
you know you're like leaning really hard
we know what you're gonna do yeah
um
this continues
one particularly hazardous aspect of the
relationship between information and
decision processes
concerns the re the revising of
decisions
it seems that having gradually and
perhaps painfully accumulated
information in support of a decision
people become
progressively more loathe to accept
contrary evidence
so this is everything we're just talking
about you make a decision you've got
some information and now we're not one
to accept anything different as edwards
and his colleagues have shown the
greater the impact of new information
the more strenuously it will be resisted
which is actually crazy
it's actually crazy dave's like i'm
heading north i'm hey i'm heading north
we're heading north right now we made
the call and i'm like hey actually bro
there's like enemy up there and you're
like we already made the call like
are you sure
total resistance
there are several reasons for this
dangerous conservatism new information
has by definition high informational
content and therefore firstly it will
require greater processing capacity
secondly it threatens a return to an
earlier state of gnawing uncertainty and
thirdly it confronts the decision maker
with the nasty thought that he may have
been wrong
no wonder he tends to turn a blind eye
i mean i talk about this in one way or
another all the time
all the time
isn't it scary to think i'd rather just
be wrong than go back to just being
uncertain
look we're going north bro there's
there's enemy up there yeah but at least
i know where i'm going
freakingdisaster.com dude
so much for a broad description of this
most vital dimension of knowledge its
prior improbability
let us return now to the other side of
the coin the problem of noise noise as
we saw is the enemy of information noise
takes up channel space and thereby
disrupts the flow of information the
more limited the channel capacity the
greater disrupting effects of noise
the more noise the less information can
be handled
and and um
again as i read this i look for some of
the things that i do wrong some of the
things i do good man i am a noise
eliminator
i am a freaking noise eliminator
there's stuff going on around me that
doesn't matter it i like give it no
no i don't give it a second of my energy
just to be able to recognize what is
noise
and go hey
that's noise we're gonna we're gonna
filter that out as opposed to the
overreaction that most people have and
and i keep in my own head going back to
things that i recall as you're as you're
reading this
i've been thinking a lot about band of
brothers
and there's a character in there if you
haven't heard it it's the book is
awesome the the
the
the tv series is like
incredibly good it's very rare that i
take a book and see the the tv version
i'm going that was really really good
the tv version is awesome there's this
character captain sobel who's kind of
like this tyrant of a leader and there's
a scene where he's leading this platoon
and he runs into like i think it's like
he's maneuvering to get to some
objective and and he ends up up against
like a barbed wire yeah this fence isn't
supposed to be those beers it's not on
the map and this guy's like
sir we can we can just go we can just
cut the fence and he's like yeah but
it's not supposed to be and he spends
all this time reacting to the idea that
this fence was not on the map and the
people around like sir
it's like a barbed wire fence we could
get through this thing in literally five
seconds
but that noise of the fence that's it's
not supposed to be here and he was
incapable of responding to what appeared
to be this and it's the inability to go
oh oh hey this is a distractor hey this
is noise we need to filter this out i
would say that's actually a better
example of this isn't what i expected
and therefore i can't accept it well
part of that yes it's beyond noise
because noise is like well there's other
stuff going on but
he's seeing something with his own two
eyes
and he's like hey them this isn't
supposed to be the map doesn't have this
well it's funny you said that because
i've been thinking about him for about
30 minutes and i chose this as the
example but where it really indexed for
me was when you gave her those three
examples yeah and i'm like dude that's
captain sobel man this is in the
character that they he talks about in
this book to reveal what this character
was like and it brought me back to
authoritarian
you know he'd do uniform inspections if
you had one thing off you lose your
weekend pat he was just such a
follow the to the to the detriment of
himself and everybody around him but you
know what the military loves a uniform
platoon they all look the same uh it's
just a character but it's it's that idea
that the incapacity to to acknowledge
those things and be able to deal with
them and happen in real time and go hey
this is no factor everybody goes oh okay
cool it's just a character but it's also
a complete and utter caricature of this
authoritarian leader we can probably
just start referring back to him
throughout this the rest of this book
it's so pretty strong
um
a glance back at figure one suggests
that not only does a senior military
commander receive more than
more than his fair share of information
but the communication system of which he
forms a part is a peculiar
peculiarly
susceptible to noise
this may be external in origin ranging
from the static on a radio link to the
delusions of a chief of staff
or it may be internal ranging from such
peripheral sources as poor eyesight a
common feature of the generals of the
crimean war
to such
centrally central and usually more
disastrous causes as defective memory
brain disease neurosis and alcoholism
uh noise from all these sources may act
upon the flow of information through a
general's head
and eventuate in decisions varying in
gravity from the mildly inept to the
utterly catastrophic but decisions hinge
upon more than available information
they also depend upon quote payoffs the
anticipated consequences of choosing one
course of action rather than another
payoffs may be positive or negative
beneficial or costly they are the
criteria according to which decisions
are made obviously if a commander gets
his criteria wrong if the possible loss
of self-esteem or social approval or
fear of offending a superior authority
is given greater waiting then more
rational considerations the scene is set
for calamity
so there you are trying to make a
decision and you're weighing
if you're gonna
lose self-esteem or if you're gonna lose
social proof which is crazy
but we know that happens
the possibility of this happening is
increased by the fact that the fog of
war unlike uncertainties which attached
to most civilian enterprises extends not
only to the input but also to the
payoffs not only does the general have
to make decisions on the basis of a
great volume of dubious information and
to meet
and meet a program of perhaps
questionable validity he may also not
know the cost and benefits of what he
does propose he is like a man who places
a bet without knowing the odds or where
the bookie might be found once the race
is over this is a freaking hard job
as well as those problems which are
inherent in any communication system the
human decision maker is the victim of
another hazard
namely that attention perception memory
and thinking are all liable to
distortion or bias by emotion and
motivation
as needs arise whether they be social or
biological
neurotic or adaptive so they act upon a
way man perceives his external world
what he attends to the sort of memories
which he conjures up and the decisions
which he makes
he is like a computer
which has not only to receive store
process and deliver information but also
has to postpone sleep cope with hunger
resist fear control anger sublimate sex
and keep up with the joneses
when it is considered that the capacity
for perception and response for memory
and thought presumably evolved for the
satisfaction of needs it is a remarkable
achievement at the best of times to keep
these informational processes of mind
free from bias by the needs which they
were originally designed to serve so you
got all this stuff going on in your head
you're genetically built this way to
have these thoughts and have these pulls
and have these biases
and it's like it's hard as hell to keep
that stuff and make your operating
system as clean as possible and then he
says in war such an achievement borders
on the miraculous and this for very one
simple reason the effects or needs the
effects of needs upon cognition are
maximized when the needs are very strong
and external reality is ambiguous or
confused it is under such conditions
that need and emotion have the greatest
freedom of maneuver the greatest
capacity for imposing themselves upon
the uncertainties of thought these are
the conditions which obtain in war and
that is freaking important
this whole idea that
emotion has the greatest freedom of
maneuver
and the greatest capacity for imposing
itself on you during times of
uncertainty and this is why this is why
people get crazy this is why people get
crazy when you go on deployment in a
combat zone this is why somebody that's
acting normal
and seems to be good to go and all of a
sudden you get you get on deployment and
they get crazy
because that emotion starts to come out
i remember i wrote a note to my buddy a
good friend of mine just just to recount
this idea
when i was lucky enough that i was one
of the first units to deploy after 9 11
to go to afghanistan and start dropping
bombs out there which was at the time
like the best thing ever it's like what
i wanted to be doing oh 9 11 happened
and everybody was sort of scrambling to
go i came back and then iraq was we we
knew that iraq was going to happen
relatively shortly after we came back
within the year and i remember writing a
note to a buddy of mine who was getting
ready to go to his first combat
deployment
and i just said the people around you
were are going to do crazy things people
that you think you know are going to do
things that totally catch you off guard
that was like my first lesson from just
and that's a very small degree compared
to what he experienced in world war ii
and the biggest takeaway when he was
asking hey hey what can i expect
it had nothing to do with
the tactics
i said the people around you are going
to do things that catch you off guard
they're going to surprise you
because the situation's gonna
their circuit breakers are gonna pop and
it's gonna blow their minds yep yep and
there's
that's a warning i've given people as
well of you you get right on deployment
i remember explaining to someone hey
it's going to get wild and
meaning people can start acting crazy
and and uh you know having people say no
they're not i'm like okay
you know fast forward two months it's
like bro what's happening with this dude
i'm like remember when i told you people
were gonna get crazy there you go
[Applause]
contemplation of what is involved in
generalship may well
may well occasionally surprise that
incompetence is not absolutely
inevitable that anyone can do the job at
all
particularly
is this so when one considers that
military decisions are often made under
conditions of enormous stress when
actual noise fatigue lack of sleep poor
food and grinding responsibility add
their quotas to the ever-present threat
of total annihilation he's like hey bro
it's a miracle anyone can pull this
off
i love the sentence actual noise actual
noise and that's in italics
i hope i said it in italics because it's
in italics
indeed the foregoing analysis of
generalship prompts the thought that it
might be better to scrap generals and
leave decision-making aspects of war to
computers
a similar argument has been has been
advanced in connection with medicine why
leave diagnosis and therapeutic
decisions to fallible human brains when
a computer
could make them with far less chance of
error the answer of course and this no
doubt contributes much to the relief of
generals and doctors that computers make
poor leaders and indifferent father
figures
they may be quick and efficient
unprejudiced sober and alert but with
all remain cold fish they do not inspire
affection with its consequent desire to
please nor do they exude a bedside
manner paradoxically they are also
perhaps just a little too infallible
they are moreover as we as far as we
know devoid of feelings what is worse
quite indifferent to outcomes of their
decisions
but while all this militates against
computers as leaders of men so-called
leadership qualities in military
commanders are just as dependent upon
the various factors outlined in our flow
chart as are any of the other responses
which a general makes
prejudice
ignorance fear of failure over
conformity and sheer stupidity may
disrupt leadership decisions as surely
as they interfere with planning or
technical decisions
all are products of the same
brain man there's a lot going on
one last point
a senior military or naval commander
does not indeed cannot act in lonely
isolation but is fettered by the
organization to which he belongs
he is like a computer or telephone
exchange whose modus operandi is based
on rules which may have little relevance
to the tasks it is called upon to
perform imagine a telephone exchange
that
for the honor of the post office has to
follow the rule that all telephonists
should have red hair 38 inch busts and
heavily littered eyes and one has some
idea of the restricting effects which an
organization may have upon its own
functioning
in these chapters that follow we shall
be examining some well-known cases of
military incompetence to discover if
possible the
precise reasons for and the common
denominators of these events for the
moment however let us consider one brief
and less well-known incident which
illustrates how the smooth flow of
information through the brains of senior
commanders may be so distorted that
their decisions prove catastrophic
the culprits in this instance are naval
not military commanders
the place is samoa
in the date 1889
seven warships three american three
german and one british are lying at acre
in the harbor of apia
they are there as naval and military
presence to watch over the interests of
their various governments in the
political upheavals that are taking
place ashore
accordingly they anchor in what has been
described as one of the most dangerous
anchorages in the world
for to call apia a harbor
at all
is at best an unfortunate euphemism
largely occupied by coral reefs this
saucer-shaped indentation lies wide open
to the north whence the great pacific
rollers come sweeping in
in fair weather apia provides an uneasy
resting place for no more than four
medium-sized ships
for seven large ships and numerous
smaller craft
under adverse conditions it is a death
trap
this was the situation in which the
seven men of war witnessed the first
bleak portense of an approaching typhoon
they got seven ships inside this little
harbor which this little harbor actually
has an open mouth to the sea full of
reefs full of regions
and it's b it's big enough for four
ships there's seven in there
even to a landsman
a rapidly darkening sky and falling
glass
squally gusts of wind and then a lull
would bode ill
for seven naval captains the signs were
unmistakable they knew they were in a
region of the world particularly subject
to typhoons which in a matter of minutes
could lash the sea into a furious hell
of boiling water they knew that such
storms generate winds traveling at
upwards of 100 knots gusts that could
snap mass like carrots
reduce deck fittings to match wood and
throw ships on their beam ends
they knew that this was the worst month
of the year and they also knew that only
three years before every ship in apia
had been sunk by such a storm
in short and in terms and in the terms
of our flow chart their stored
information coupled with present input
pointed to only one decision to get up
and get out
and as if this was not enough the
urgency weighing of weighing anchor and
putting to see was respectively
suggested by subordinate officers so you
got a freaking massive storm approaching
by the way what was it a year three
years before every ship in the harbor
had been sunk
we've got subordinate officers that are
saying hey captain we should get out of
here
but the captains of the warship
but the captains of the warships were
also naval officers
and so they denied the undeniable and
stayed where they were
their behavior has been described as in
quote error of judgment that will
forever remain a paradox in human
psychology end quote
when the typhoon struck
its effects were tragic and inevitable
without sea room their anchors dragging
under the pressure of the mountainous
seas their holes and rigging crushed by
the fury of the wind three of the
warships collided be
collided before being swept onto the
jagged reefs of coral another sank in
deep water two more were wrecked upon
the beach of all the ships in the harbor
the only survivor was a british corvette
which thanks to its powerful engines and
superb seamanship squeaked through to
the open sea
why did the naval commanders versed in
the ways of the sea and provided with
ample warning thus hazard their ships
and their lives of their men
a superficial answer might be pride
or fear of appearing cowardly or fear of
criticism from their superiors
these matters are to be pursued in later
chapters for the moment the apparently
encourageable behavior of these men
illustrates how decision process can be
thrown into disarray by noise of
internal origin
and how in this instance anyway
incompetence cannot be attributed to
ignorance
or ordinary stupidity
the the it's an into the the focus of
that is this is an internal noise it's
it's internal they they knew what was
coming they could see what was coming
there's no lack of communication they're
watching the storm come
they have the history they have they
know what's happened in this harbor
before there's like everything is clear
and yet the decision
by seven captains i guess six one of
them made it out sounds like he squeaked
out though they all make the wrong
decision
how does that happen
no external factors can be blamed in
this situation
it's internal
it's internal noise
that comes from our own
psychology
so
well two and a half hours deep um
i say we call it for today
uh
this book is going to be uh
there's so much in this book
um and and i'll start to speed up a
little bit i think as we as we push into
the next podcast um
hit some of
high waves for the section where they
cover
the historical disasters but like i said
it's not like he just talks about the
historical disasters and explain what
happens he starts to explain why
decisions are getting made where the ego
comes into play who's who's offending
one another what these internal
decision disasters are caused by
and
and i'm telling you it is a great
warning
for all of us military civilian
business
family
and
you can probably already see the the
this is what we talk about all the time
this book these these topics are what we
talk about all the time and the examples
bring them to
to even clearer
light
we'll get into it on the next podcast
until then uh carrie we are we are
trying
to prevent our own
incompetence as much as possible in
every aspect of our lives we are what uh
what uh what can you recommend to us to
try and
mitigate our own incompetence that's not
a very high goal is it
mitigating our own incompetence
what do you got so we want to battle
incompetence we want to be more capable
not less capable
um we want a clean operating system oh i
like where you're going with this
operate clean
right uh-huh so
how can we do that we're going to do
that with a little bit of jocko fuel
a little discipline go
a little rtd
in a can
possibly some afterburner orange
or
mango mayhem from the big dog echo
charles who
the big dog echo charles the hawaiian
that name rings a bell oh the guy who's
job
oh yeah i forgot his name the big dog
echo
oh people are going to freak out oh man
k dogs on here they're like wait a
second what happened to echo charles
cover move yeah okay how about that so
he couldn't make it today echo charles
was otherwise detained right on so okay
dog had k-dog had to step up to the
plate how'd it feel in the hot seat over
there
because you've been behind the scenes
i've been behind the scenes a little bit
i've been in the i've been in the other
side of the camera yeah yeah yeah now
you're front and center now we're in
here and maybe echo's like he's on the
ropes
echo is an institution as far as i'm
concerned
and i i'm that makes one of us
i am happy to fill in though man
honestly it's uh it's super cool to sit
at the table i've said this to you and
probably dave two men hollowed ground
the people who've sat around this table
man it's it's something special so super
cool to be able to do it uh today for
sure right now so we're getting some
jack-o-fuel jack-o-fuel.com
chocofuel.com we're getting some
discipline go going to wawa and just
clearing shelves that's where we're at
if you go to wawa and you clear a shelf
let me tell you what you're doing you're
helping every other trooper in america
that's what you're doing because as
other convenience chains see what's
going on at wawa they're like oh oh okay
we got it so roll into wawa and just get
some just clear shelves
um huawei's got something going on right
now right with you discipline yeah if
it's october when you're listening to
this yeah right now you you buy one and
you get another one for a buck maybe
missed it which is kind of dope well we
didn't miss anything this comes out
tonight tomorrow night yeah right
k-dog's just gonna roll right in hey hot
get it get out the wobble for that bogo
action
uh oh look at you let's not get one
though because it's it's a buck buy one
get one for a dollar right yeah
uh joint warfare
super krill
um
these these things are all battle
against that noise we're talking about
body body noise physical noise that
elbow noise oh you got some elbow noise
bro always well not you know i got some
shoulder noise
if i'm telling you if i don't if i if i
miss out on joint warfare it's a problem
that's why i don't miss out on it joint
warfare and super krill that's my that's
my go-to man get rid of that noise
how about that mulk
dave you get on that multi
are you still on strawberry yeah dude
you've been on strawberry for a while i
don't know what's gonna ever i mean i i
have them all i got a line up in my
closet or my my pantry button it's it's
like um you know it's like afterburner
orange for me that's what i'm going to
it's strawberry's the best do you
so right now you're drinking what back
savage what do you got over there i got
a dac right in front so at the
at the gym here we were out of
afterburner orange which i know is no
big surprise to you
but do you ever think ah
i almost wavered today on jocko palmer i
was like you know maybe i'll go tropic
thunder cause tropic thunder especially
when it's cold
it's freaking legit but you're still
strawberry yes
and milk strawberry that's it dude i'd
mix nothing in that it's strawberry and
milk and that's it
i don't like
and hey no criticism that's your game
but like in the stuff that people put in
there and like i i put in the shaker cup
i shake it up when i drink it and
there's nothing i want to add echo
charles over here he's got to go to the
grocery store what do you know what i'm
saying the frozen banana game changer
all day all day that frozen banana
something about that tell us you're
putting that word huh oh man she's never
how does it when you you got to blend it
then too
that's a whole issue
here's the thing with me
i like to eat sure but you know some
people
they they they have like a whole it's a
it's a ritual right and they're gonna
get they go to the store and they're
like picking stuff up and then they fire
up the grill and you know i got a nice
grill and everything i
i you i'll put in the microwave like i'm
not i'm not firing that thing up i'm one
of those people we're looking for
efficiencies oh i will i will open up a
can of chicken from costco and just
that's dinner if my wife didn't make
good food i would just be eating you
know a
a can of
of of
chicken you'd be on that k dog yeah i
played the k-dog routine
it's the single life homie yeah you're
just full-on in it yeah two cups of
green beans some hawaiian rolls
you're good to go you're ready to rock
and roll
so
but you know what is good that's why i'm
not i'm not exploring the freaking half
frozen well ripe banana or whatever it
is we're doing right i'm over here i'm
with dave i'm like milk malk we're good
but here's the shake it up for me that
milk mulch combo yeah my scale you know
what i'm giving it i'd give it a 10.
yeah i'm giving it a 10. it's like i'm
just suffering through the seven six
point negative no it's a 10. that's
that's where all this other stuff you're
doing you know what's going to get you
to a 10 yeah that's where i'm at right
now so i don't need it yeah i i'm the
same way now i will say
um
[Music]
i'm not solo on one flavor right now i'm
i'm bouncing around i bounce around i
used to go like one month on a flavor
and then i go in three weeks on another
flavor then go back to another flavor
for a month i'm kind of i'm kind of
getting crazy right now i'll be you know
i'd be even doing you know dip mixing up
during the day
you know lunch is gonna be some peanut
butter dinner's gonna be some mint right
we've got some food
i'm over here close-minded not free
thinking yeah i got strawberry i'm gonna
stick with strawberry for about 25 years
we'll adjust some other time down the
road
uh wah-wah for the drinks vitamin shop
get all the stuff at the vitamin shop
awesome jockofuel.com what commissary oh
that's right
navy commissary that's right that's
right good call kdog 100 we're in there
man we're in there um
jackalful.com if you yeah also subscribe
if you subscribe you get the shipping
for free what up just
where do we stand on greens
okay we have we have greens choco greens
um they're amazing dude they are amazing
they really truly are amazing yes
they are
they're
hard to make um if you look at the
ingredients list
it's all organic the whole product
together is not certified organic
because we haven't gone through that
process yet but every ingredient in
there is
i think every ingredient is organic so
it's it's hard to make it
um so that's why i'm not talking about
it a ton because people that are kind of
in the know
like i'm not trying to screw them and
just tell everyone that this is the
greatest beverage yeah it's certainly
it certainly is the greatest greens but
and not even close it's not even close
it tastes delicious go look at the
ingredients list too it is the best
quality sweetened with monk fruit
it
you know what i've been doing is i've
been having that like let let's because
sometimes you know i get done with the
steak at night
and
i want dessert
but
i'm full
so that milk is sort of looking like a
little bit much
out comes the grease
out comes the greens it's like what like
uh wine people they drink whatever it is
a port
right a poor
can i get glass of pork when i'm feeling
that way since i'm a freaking savage i'm
just ordering up a class a glass of
greens shaking up the ground shaking
some green i brought it up and i don't
want to alienate the the listeners who
maybe don't have access and and you can
edit all the stuff out if if no people
have access but here's the deal on the
greens
you want to go back to the three
categories of leaders which is the fully
anticipates the outcome you're shocked
by the outcome and can't process the
outcome
when i drank my first container of
greens i was squarely in category c like
what is happening
the delta between what i expected and
what i got it was insane those things
are it is unbelievable how good they
taste for what you think it's gonna
taste like because it's greens
it was an absolute
mind-blowing experience
well i've been doing it in the morning
and it does give you like a little bit
of kick right that other kick and it's
just good to go so yeah listen if you if
you go online you order the greens
awesome if if we're out we're making
more as fast as we can i apologize
logistics wins wars
um we're working it we're losing that
war right now
we're we're in the game and we'll try
and get you some more that's like the
kind of thing you want to subscribe to
because you want that order getting
filled it's so good don't want to be
waiting when are you drinking it dave
every morning it's like in the morning
so just immediately into my habit
pattern i haven't since i got it i
haven't missed a day it was it
it's everything you just said i just
want people to realize like what you
think you're getting with greens like
everybody knows what greens are cool
they're healthy you sort of need to
stomach them and just kind of like hold
your nose and and get to them because
they're good for you yeah go to your
lawn mower get the clippings out
put it in the blender that's what you
think you're getting right and you're
not there the origin media team did this
uh like double blind video like double
blind study video from the immersion
camp yeah and it's awesome man people
are just like all day oh my gosh this is
green it doesn't even it doesn't even
compute that it can be that good for
category c there you go
speaking of origin we got uh geez rash
guards apparel coming out of origin usa
right yeah doing boots up there now yeah
we're doing it all
i'm gonna we're we're gonna make
everything that we use
in life that's the goal the goal is to
make everything that we that we use in
life and we're going to make it in
america and let me tell you what that's
a that's no small task
and we're getting it done
jeans
boots we got work pants coming out
i saw those on the ground i'll tell you
what man that's another thing like we're
going to make them as fast as we can
as soon as people get a pair or see a
pair
they're they're going to be gone um and
you know what we we're up in our
capacity again logistics wins wars i
know that and we are working it um
and it's we're in a good place because
the rest of people that do this they got
to rely on a foreign supply chain even
in some cases a communist supply chain
with literally
fabrics that are made by communists who
you know have a dictatorship in their
country and they're paying people you
know one dollar a week to make the
material
so
this is like uh
strategic for america
that's why we're doing it could we hey
could we freaking cut some corners and
up that profit margin by whatever sure
we could but we're freaking not going to
so if you want some if you wear clothes
[Music]
then you might want to get your clothes
from a strategic
partner of yourself and that is us
at origin usa
what up
i got nothing else for that man dirt to
the shirt baby um
we if you're also looking for
clothes to say represent the path you
can find those on jocko store
junkostore.com
we got
discipline equals freedom we got um
take the high ground on there still
um i like how you're co-opting some of
echo's phrases you're kind of like
you're you're you're utilizing them you
know
not totally
uh copying them 100 but you're you're
catching the vibe and you're putting
your k-dog spin on it
just been watching the master work from
the corner of the camera
shout out echo charles um yeah man so
got all that going on at jacostore.com
also have a t-shirt subscription from
the big dog echo charles called the
shirt locker
where he makes
rad
um shirts with layers from the podcast
so if you're if you're about those
layers if you listen to the podcast
you're like yes like i'm about the
layers check out the shirt locker echoes
cranking out a new shirt every month
with a different layer from the podcast
presented on them
both of you are wearing dude let's try
the shirt right now check it out the
sock t-shirt we represent right we we
come here to to
get after it and we're representing that
right and so
me and echo like sometimes show up
wearing the same shirt today me dave
burke showed up rocking the
um sog
shirt which is
legit the socks support so echo showed
it to me he's like he's approved for and
i said hey man we can't be running
around just throwing sog
on to a t-shirt and being good with that
any more than you can just throw a
trident on a shirt and be like oh yeah
i'll just represent
so
the way we got around that
is by putting support on there so it's
like you know like when if you're if
you're maybe you support a local biker
gang
but you're not in the biker gang but you
got friends
you can wear that biker gang
stuff but you gotta have support on
there because you're not trying to claim
at all you don't wanna try to claim sock
but we freaking support songs 100
absolutely
um so all that's going on at uh jocko
store.com yeah uh subscribe to this
podcast wherever you subscribe to
podcast we also have jocko unraveling
and that's with daryl cooper dc
we just did one about afghanistan that
was kind of the
lead up to this one a little bit just
because
we were debriefing what happened on
afghanistan and and clearly there's some
military incompetence that
has risen up in the ranks and we started
to address that on on jocko unraveling
with daryl cooper got the grounded
podcast which we haven't done a while
and warrior kid podcast i know i got to
get back on that one so subscribe to
those check them out also we have jocko
underground jocko underground.com we
have a
a secondary podcast where like i started
off talking today about how we talk
about psych psychology on that one quite
a bit
um
because that stuff interests me and that
stuff also helps you understand the
world and if you understand the world
and you understand people you can be a
better leader you can be a better person
you can be a better mom dad whatever
yet it didn't quite some of those
subjects don't quite fit into
this podcast so we made jocko
underground documentaryground.com
and that's that podcast is like a little
reward for support
because we wanted to create a
alternative and alternative platform in
case of these platforms
which they haven't caused any problems
yet hey we're on board we're here we
appreciate it we appreciate the
platforms
but
you can't put all your reliance on
something that you have no control over
and we don't really have any control
over these large platforms so we wanted
to make something just in case hey we'll
be here
but just in case things get wild
we got the jocko underground.com so
thanks if you want to subscribe to that
cost eight dollars and eighteen cents a
month if you can't afford that look we
still want you in the game email
assistance
jockowunderground.com
appreciate that we got a youtube channel
where we put up this video you can see
the new song
underground or sog
shirt locker t-shirts on there which is
cool subscribe to that
and also origin usa if you want to watch
what's going on at origin strategic
partner of america you can go to origin
usa check that out psychological warfare
made an album
telling echo
helping echo charles get through some
moments of weakness
maybe he needs one for
you know coming to work
definitely check out psychological
warfare very legit though
uh flip side canvas dakota meyer
if you wanna hang cool stuff on your
wall check that out books new book
coming out final spin dave
what's your assessment
read it it's so good and
stand by for the audiobook there's some
oh yeah so on the audio if you get the
audio book of that i read the audiobook
and then
we did dave and i did uh about an hour
conversation about
just
a review talking about the characters
the character development the lack of
character development the plot
development the lack of plot development
the words used the lack of words used
just all these things that uh
will will definitely be interesting and
it's it's been amazing so far the books
the books coming out you should do like
a virtual book signing or something
would be cool to get that out there i
think i am doing a virtual book signing
and i'm not 100 sure where and and
actually
check this out speaking of virtual book
signing in november i'm going to do two
jocko lives
jocko lives ready one in looks like san
diego california in november and then
austin texas in november i think those
are the only dates look things are wild
right now with the
the covid and the protocols and all this
stuff and people are really sketched out
especially some of the
some of the places you can give you can
do these events some of them have
whatever they're freaked out about it so
we found some places that are down for
the cause so we're gonna do a gig i'm
gonna do a gig jocko live november
in san diego and november in
austin texas so keep an eye out for that
it'll be an intro to final spin
it gives you time to read it the book
does not take long to read
so
you'll be able to get the book get the
book when it comes out november 9th and
then by the time
november 13th or november 20th which i
think are the dates on those two i'll be
there and you can ask me questions about
it i'll talk about some of uh some of
where all that came from the darkness in
my brain
uh that's final spin
leadership strategies and tactics field
manual the code the evaluation the
protocols discipline equals freedom
field manual
way of the warrior kid one two three
four miking the dragons about faced by
hackworth extreme ownership and the
dichotomy of leadership
check out these books if you like books
if you don't like books get the audio
books that's my recommendation echelon
front we have a leadership consultancy
leadership is the solution
what's the problem the leadership is the
solution
well what's the problem leadership is
the solution that's what i'm trying to
tell you and that's what we will tell
you and that's what we will teach you at
echelonfranco ashlandfront.com
look if you want to come to one of our
live events the next live event that we
have is in las vegas
the muster october 28th and 29th
two days
it was a deep dive into this information
we also have field training exercises
and we have a thing called ef
battlefield where we go and tour
battlefields check out all that stuff go
to events at echelonfront.com if you
want us to come work with your company
same thing um
we also have
an online training
academy called extreme ownership academy
extremeownership.com this is
this stuff is not easy and you don't get
good at it by reading a book and be like
oh cool i'm good to go it doesn't work
that way
you need to work at it continually go to
extremeownership.com come and ask me a
question on there i'm literally live how
long are we on there for today an hour
and a half yeah hour and 20 minutes i
guess yeah
dave and i are responding to your
questions life is on there jamie's on
there like we are there jp's on there
you want to ask us a question come and
ask a question
live
and it's not crowded you will get your
question answered how's that
extremeownership.com if you want to help
service members active and retired their
families gold star families
check out mark lee's mom mama lee she's
got a charity organization she is
helping
all kinds
of people get through all kinds of
struggles
go to america's mightywarriors.org
if you want to check that out
and if you want more of my lengthy
lectures
which today was absolutely one of them
you want you want to hear
carries
chiming in
you want to hear dave's analytical
appraisals you can find us
on the interwebs on twitter on the gram
on facebook echo is that echo charles
but he's not here today so don't follow
him
instead check out k-dog what is it k-dog
carrie helton carrie underscore hilton
you couldn't get carrie no underscore
helton i tried i hit the guy up and
everything
no response he denied you oh you were
trying to make that social media move
100 percent man give me my name bro
is he is his name carrie helton too yeah
yeah all one word and uh yeah i shot a
message i was like you know very civil
hey dude
uh we you know
interested in your handle
is that something i could get off you
he's like that's my name bro no response
dude yeah scene left me on red it hurts
but you can find me at carrie underscore
left me on red left me on red so had
read the message and just
so my kids harass me because i do that
in real life
like they're talking and i just don't
respond they walk away and they say oh
you're going to leave me on red wow yep
nice and i i think i do that
fairly regularly i mean you've done it
to me
dave can you relate to this i left you
on red before
i try not to interact too much
[Laughter]
but sure
actually actually you just sent me i was
like
stupid busy over the last few days and
you i i i just remember that you sent me
some texts that were absolutely left
unread
uh and then dave burke at david r burke
um and
look thanks to all the men and women out
there right now in the army navy air
force marines who are
competent leaders
who are holding the line in a violent
and unpredictable world and also thanks
to our competent
police and law enforcement firefighters
paramedics emts dispatchers correctional
officers border patrol secret service
all first responders you have an
incredibly difficult job
but you keep us safe and we appreciate
it and everyone else out there
open up your mind
don't be the person that is loathed to
accept contrary evidence to what you
already believe don't be that person
don't get stuck in that rut
open your mind free your mind
and become better by
continuing
to always absorb new information in fact
look for it
seek it out
and keep getting after it
and until next time this is dave
and carrie
and
out